foreign
good morning welcome to Edna
I'm opening the public hearing on Senate
hey Jack uh good morning chair McGuire
and um members of house Edna feels like
I was just here good to see you again
this morning for the record my name is
suprentice and I am the state center
from District Five representing 15
communities large part of Grafton a part
of Sullivan and one community in
Merrimack County today I'm here to
introduce Senate Bill 150 and Senate
Bill 150 is going to amend the we're
looking to amend the composition of the
family mediator certification board and
I do have the chair here with me to
speak to this as well as to propose
what what may be a technical correction
so but before we get into that I just
wanted to share with you all that back
in December honey Hastings and some of
you may remember honey Hastings who is
an attorney who spent years in this
building and over at the State House
advocating on behalf of the legal
community and family mediators she had
contacted me about doing this work
because the the this family mediator
certification board is on it has been
unable to meet in over a year because
they don't have a quorum and you can
actually look at the website and see
where it goes from the ability to meet
to you know meetings being canceled and
very you know that's one of the things
that I looked at so we had this
conversation because honey and I have
worked together before and unfortunately
before I could even file the language
she passed away suddenly
and so I met I dearly missed the
opportunity to work with her again but
it it made sense to me more than uh more
you know more than and really now that
this is the work of honey and we need to
um I'd like to see this through to the
end on her behalf so that's how this all
got started in 2022 as I spoke about
meetings being canceled out of 12
meetings 11 were canceled
um so
by way of background Family Mediation is
a process in which a neutral third party
facilitates the resolution of family
disputes by assisting the parties and
creating their own voluntary agreements
it's designed to be less adversarial
than the traditional court process in
order to act as a family mediator in New
Hampshire you need to be certified
the office of professional licensure
and certification represents the family
mediator certification board so they are
housed and work out of there this board
was established to develop and maintain
ethical professional and educational
standards for the certification of
family mediators to safeguard our the
states our state citizens the board is
also responsible for investigating
complaints and taking disciplinary
action as authorized so I'm going to run
through not run through that would be
actually running I'm going to speak to
the changes in each section section one
of the bill reduces the number of public
members from two to one the number of
family mediators on the board from five
to three it maintains a judge it
maintains one member of the New
Hampshire bar and it removes the marital
master and mental health professional
section 2 prescribes the terms how
vacancies are filled and how persistent
absences will be addressed Section 3
reduces the number of meetings from 12
to 6 per year
this bill also outlines the transition
that will need to take place to move
from move the Quorum from 11 to 6 as
well as phasing out of the marital
master and the mental health
professional I again I thank you for the
opportunity I would welcome questions
and if I can't answer them I'm so glad
to have Fran Lane with me who's the
chair of this board and one of the
things that Fran is going to speak to
that
I I think we're going to need to
consider here is in section three
and I'll pass this email on to chair
McGuire it it recites that a quorum
shall be half of the membership
appointed by the governor and Council
but only fought but only five members
are so really what it does is it instead
of being based on six it's based on five
and cutting that in half is 2.5 and
really doesn't work so we're gonna need
to I believe make a change there or
hopefully in committee you all can make
a change and between Fran and I we could
Supply that language okay
so
thank you again for the opportunity good
to see you again and um I'll take
questions
thank you Senator are there any
questions representative Lucas
thank you looking at three B hold on
three let me get you that's in the
Quorum part
um
if I understand correctly if um
you know seats are are vacant that will
reduce will not reduce the Quorum it
sounds like it would and my concern is
to get down to one person or something
and they'd be the whole thing I mean so
I I have some concerns about
you know it automatically reducing the
Quorum if people you know if the seats
vacant I understand why with not being
able to meet there might be a desire for
that but I I don't know if you can
representative Lucas thank you for the
question it's a a good observation I
can't comment on it
at the moment I'd like to bring this to
Fran Lane and see if we can provide more
clarity there I just haven't had enough
time to think about it all right thank
you you're welcome
other questions
I have one Senator when I was looking at
the current statute it still has fee fee
setting Authority with the board and it
also so I'd like to remove that if
that's not a problem
since the fee setting Authority is being
okay and and also
there's a line that says that the board
can create requirements for licensure
that are not in statute and I would very
much like to remove that and simply add
any
requirements created by rule into the
statute
rather than statute creating it what
rules to create the requirements is that
right the requirement should be in the
statute and merely echoed in the rule
not created in the role okay that makes
it thank you okay so but so while we're
working on the Quorum issues we'll uh
we'll start that and um we might change
the effective date depending on the
other changes
understood okay okay so
anyone else
okay I am I do have to go backward to
starting session so I'm Gonna Leave You
in the capable hands of friend Lane and
we can all
um represent uh chair McGuire we can
continue to communicate about these
changes again thank you all and have a
great day okay thank you senator
sure I have a question actually probably
of you and that is um was there anything
in the initially proposed licensing
changes to hb2 that related to this
board just I'm wondering no okay
now this this was an initiative of the
board that it's or our Senate Apprentice
that the board is too unwieldy as
currently constituted I just want to
make sure there wasn't a conflict
between things that might happen
um thank you for checking into that
thanks
good morning Madam chairman member
support my name is Francis Lane I live
in newfields New Hampshire on a personal
note I'll say the last time I was in
this building I was across the hall 44
years ago taking the bar exam
I am a New Hampshire attorney I'm very
pleased to be here
um in 2009 I also became certified as a
marital mediator in the state of New
Hampshire on in 2019 I was appointed to
serve on the marital mediator
certification board here in Concord I
was on the board on and served as a
chairperson in the past year 2022 I just
stepped down from that board this past
month
um
I uh we talked earlier Senator
Apprentice president mentioned honey
Hastings who was a friend of mine since
um our board experienced a number of
different difficulties beginning with
the pandemic in terms of forum issues
and most severely in 2022 the past year
where we were only able to to hold one
meeting
for for Quorum issues by Statute the
board was originally constituted with 11
members a judge a marital Master two
members of the public a mental health
professional
um and five mediator certified by the
conflict resolution Association and also
a New Hampshire attorney
um this past year as I mentioned we were
unable to have a full Quorum of the
board in order to conduct our business
month to month and as I indicated and I
think
um Senator also mentioned we only had
one meeting in 2022 which created a
number of different problems for the
board many of them which were very
significant with regards to licensing
issues approval of courses Etc honey
Hastings was in contact with me to
discuss this problem over the the course
of the past year and together with other
mediators there was discussion about
making Necessary changes and updating
the the statute with regard to our
Quorum and what you have before you is
the product of that work
um I I'm very uh be very happy to
explain any parts of this new
legislation that you may have I would
point out that in reading it again
yesterday I realized that uh maybe honey
had overlooked something
um in that one of her last conversations
she had with me was she was proposing to
eliminate a New Hampshire bar member on
the board and in our discussion I
um urged her not to consider doing that
and to leave the bar member in there but
I realize now
um she did again by way of this
statutory draft include the bar member
but under 3C it reads that a quorum
shall be half of the membership
appointed by the governor
this statutory
um provision would provide that five
members of the board are appointed by
the governor
one the judge is appointed by the
administrative judge so it's not it's
not subject to appointment by the
governor so I think that that was just
an ambiguity that she made a change by
adding the lawyer back in but not
changing that provision I think that
that may lead to an ambiguity with
regard to 3C and if I might suggest
perhaps that language could basically
just be revised to read that a quorum
shell be three members appointed by the
governor
again five according to this
um legislative proposal would be
appointed by the governor and this
simply indicate that three
according to the structure of this this
bill three would be the Baseline Quorum
necessary for the board to act or have
uh any formal votes and I think that
um I would like to try to address your
question about that if I understood it
um it wouldn't be reducing the number of
of members needed to be physically
present
below three
and if there were not going to be three
members present out of a board meeting
the board could not proceed with any
formal votes on any any business
thank you representative blackis
I think with the change of proposing and
the language to make it uh three members
then clearly it wouldn't drop but I
think the existing language
um the Quorum would automatically drop
if you had vacant seats and it could
drop down to one I mean that's how I
read the language but with the change
you're proposing that wouldn't be an
issue but but the the the board could
not proceed with meetings well except
instead of quorums originally instead of
follow-ups Quorum shall be half the
membership appointed by the governor and
Council vacancies shall not count and so
if you had let's say all seats
um
vacant other than one that was appointed
by the governor the clear meaning of the
language is that they could have a
meeting and take action with one member
I don't see how to read it otherwise
maybe I'm missing something I think that
your suggestion of just changing that to
three makes very unambiguous
very much
unambiguous
yes I know that she was thinking of four
um at the time and that's why I think
she shared the language in there it
would be cut to you know one half of the
members but again in a a final
discussion
um uh there had been a decision to keep
the the lawyer member as a member of the
board
so okay
thank you
um
what else I would I have one question do
you know how many family mediators are
certified
the last time that there was a
discussion on this I believe the
response was 61. 61. apparently I should
point out that close enough certified
family mediator serve in all the courts
and the family courts in the state of
New Hampshire I I presently serve in
Brentwood okay let's I just want to know
if we how many people we're dealing with
representative Simon thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
um over the last year when you've had 11
out of 12 meetings canceled due to lack
of Quorum how many people on average
were available for those meetings
are our Quorum
um came down to five well yeah I
understand that but so you sent out a
memo saying
um can you come how many people on
average responded Yes I can be there for
each meeting so did you have three
respondents who said yes we would have
been able to make it we would have had a
quorum under this but we can't meet the
five standard
foreign
we seem to always have one one person
who could not make it and and we were at
five members and we needed a quorum of
five
gotcha I don't know if that answered
your question it does yes thank you yeah
I was a follow-up real quick
um I was under the assumption that you
had 11 people on the board and you
couldn't make the Quorum but you only
had five members on the board and you
needed all five to make the Quorum I
think another thing that might help you
is that
um the statute
um that exists right now recites to be a
judge and a mural Master the mayoral
Master retired and there are no more
Maryland Masters in New Hampshire
um for over two years we were not able
to find a mental health member to to
join the board and we were not able to
find public members that were willing to
voluntarily serve okay so it created a
very significant problem for us thank
you
any other questions
it is it is a bill that's very
desperately needed
thank you very much we hope we will deal
with it
um
that's the last card I have on Senate
Bill 150 is there anyone else who wishes
okay seeing none I will close the public
hearing and
do you want me to put together an
amendment based on the comments that we
um today if you want to because I think
we've got
um there are a few changes that we
wanted to make I believe one had to do
with the fee setting
right there's two
we'll we'll work on it together okay we
we don't want to pass the bill as is
okay thank you okay and
we the next hearing is at 10 45 so we
foreign
all right good morning uh I'm opening
the hearing on Senate Bill 147 and I
call the prime sponsor Senator Innis
good morning thank you madam chairwoman
and welcome good morning committee
members
um I'm here to
um Dan Ennis District Seven Bradford New
Hampshire here to introduce Senate bill
147.
um this is a bill that is brought
forward at the request of the board of
dental examiners and it has some
Provisions in it regarding anesthesia
and the administration of such but
essentially uh it does a couple of
things the bill changes the constitution
of the board of dental examiners to
include a dentist with a current permit
to administer anesthesia which I think
is an important addition to the board to
provide a perspective that isn't
presently there and it provides guidance
regarding permits to dental facilities
and the establishment of qualifications
and requirements of facilities where
sedation is performed it's pretty
straightforward bill I think it does
some very good things particularly
around anesthesia and getting more of a
voice in that area and as we know
anesthesia is an important and
um an important medical procedure but
one that needs careful monitoring and
should be watched by the board so with
that if there are any basic questions
I'm happy to take those but I know there
are some folks behind me who will
testify to this bill who have much more
knowledge on the subject than I
very well said Senator are there any
questions
no thank you thank you very much
all right representative shuitt
and yes you should introduce your
Amendment
thank you madam chair for the record I'm
representative Diane schuett I represent
Merrimack 12 which is now just the town
of Pembroke
um I am pleased to introduce
Amendment 2023
1239h and this this amendment was placed
before your seat there are copies for
other people yes I believe everyone on
the committee has copies and there are
some spheres on the table
and
um this this amendment
takes a step of
um answering some of the questions that
had Arisen in the Senate clarifies
primarily that the administration of
either moderate or deep
sedation or anesthesia for children
eight years and younger and the language
is language that was agreed to by the
New Hampshire Dental society and the
oral and
maxillofacial I think I got that right
surgeons
and so that's the language that you will
see the one thing that I will point out
the addition that looks a little strange
is amending section five
if you look at your copy of the Senate
amended bill
Section 5 is on the very back page and
if you look at line seven
I haven't to notice that to read as
follows is repeated twice so I figured
while we were doing the amendment I'd
thank you for re explaining that it
looked like this the second page of the
amendment was missing right
okay so if there are any questions if
there are any technical questions
some of the dentists and representatives
behind me would be glad to answer them
and are there any questions
representative Simon thank you madam
chair
um just looking at the first section uh
requiring the dentist member shall have
a current permit to administer general
anesthesia anesthesia and deep sedation
um there are five year terms on the
board this takes place 60 days after
passage is there an open seat to be
filled with that at the moment or how is
that going to be handled I'm sorry I'm
having difficulty hearing I'm sorry uh
representative so this bill goes into
effect 60 days after passage the terms
on the board are five years do you know
if there's an open seat on the board
right now that can be filled by somebody
with this criteria or would they have to
free one and if so how I do not know I'm
assuming uh there are representatives of
the board here I'm sure they can answer
them okay
thank you
other questions thank you very much
representative
Michael orback
all right
I guess he's not here oh I'm here oh I'm
sorry
excuse me that's how my board treats me
too so
[Laughter]
good morning Madam chair and thank you
to you and the members of this committee
uh for uh your consideration my name is
Michael Auer back for the record I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
Dental Society we represent over a
thousand dentists hygienists assistants
and dental professionals throughout the
state our focus is on the practice of
Dentistry as well as the patients we
serve uh I'm coming here today uh in
full support of this bill as amended and
I would like to bring forward if I make
I we have a doctors Lori Rosado and Dr
Mark Abel who are able to speak to your
their professional credentials as they
pertain to the use of these amendments
but what I will say is that in our
opinion this bill uh speaks to some of
our core concerns uh if the amendment
speaks to uh strengthens the rules uh so
that credentials of individuals like the
oral surgeons in particular are
underscored and that patient safety is
also maintained and furthermore that at
the uh
um sorry that there are no gaps in in
care caused by any changes in in the
rules at this time I would like to bring
forward uh Dr Laurie Rosado who I
uh we do have a question of course
representative thank you um just want to
clarify by the amendment you mean the
Senate Amendment or the amendment that
was just introduced the amendment that
thank you representative for your
question there was amendment that was
just introduced by representative
schuette okay thank you thank you
okay yes please Dr Rosado
was there another question I'm sorry
there was another question for me it's
over here yes
so it's okay so anesthesia in dentistry
is not new
and I'm just wondering what prompted
this change
as I understand it this was uh an
amendment that was brought not by the
board of dental examiners but by uh uh
Senator Innis and others in the Senate
that they were concerned about uh the
impacts of having an additional person
in the room not understanding that and
most oral surgeons offices uh they do
have additional people they do have a
digital training there were a lot of
questions that were raised in the Senate
when the amendment was was offered in
the Senate
um questions about what are the
credentials of oral surgeons do they
have safety protocols in place and uh
and to be frank I think the Senate ran
out of time before crossover uh and
wanted to bring it to the house to
answer some of those more detailed
questions which is where this amendment
came from thank you thank you
representative I do I have a question
was this in um a result of the audit of
the board of dental examiners this
amendment representative the bill the
bill I believe was a standard rules
package as I said the the final
amendment that pertains to lifting the
exemption for oral surgeons that was
brought separately not by the board's
design it was an amendment that was
brought by uh in the Senate
okay thank you
Dr Rosado
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is Dr Laurie Rosado
I'm a practicing dentist here in Concord
I'm also the chair of the governmental
Affairs Council for the New Hampshire
Dental Society I'm also the volunteer
dentist that serves 10 public schools in
the Concord area in surrounding towns
as a dentist who sees children a fair
amount of children patient safety is
obviously Paramount whether it's for
children or anybody but here we're
speaking about children
although nationally it's very rare to
have a patient death under anesthesia
that's a concern here it's very rare
we're fortunate to that's never happened
here in the state of New Hampshire
because of the procedures and protocols
that have always been put in place oral
surgeons have always practiced under an
exemption for decades or or longer and
that's always what's been in place
that's what's being asked to change
through this bill and through this
amendment and we do support the
amendment that representative shewitt
has put forward to change the age frame
of which oral surgeons or dental
anesthesiologists can sedate a patient
as a solo practitioner again oral
surgeon specifically I've always
practiced with trained providers with
them they're not oral surgeons their
assistants that go through a far more
Advanced Training System than your
typical dental assistants they go
through what's called a dance training
which is a dental anesthesia training so
oral surgeons in the state have always
practiced extremely safety having those
types of assistance present
as a general dentist I'm not qualified
to administer moderate or deep sedation
and I can't answer a lot of questions on
that we have experts in the room for
that however as a provider of Children's
Dental Care I can tell you how a dentist
um
engages into a situation where a child
needs to be sedated so for instance a
child comes to my office that has a
severe Dental infection that I'm not and
they need sedation for that whether it's
due to anxiety or medical history Etc
they need they need sedation I then
refer to an oral surgeon usually I can
refer to a pediatric dentist who then
can find appropriate measures of
sedation however pediatric dentists
usually can't do that immediately
because they can't do that within their
office themselves they rely on a
hospital setting or other modes of
treatment an oral surgeon can sedate the
child if they deem the child is is
capable to undergo sedation and again
there's parameters that they look at
with that being age Airway size weight
and other things and ages and always the
the determining factor it's the size of
the child Etc again there's experts in
the room that can speak to that
the one thing that we get concerned
about is is if there if if this
exemption is taken away from the oral
surgeon this adds a lot of cost to the
parent of the child a cost in the realm
of 800 to a thousand dollars now we
can't let cost be the determining Factor
here safety has to be the number one
factor here
um of which we've always had that in our
state
um but the the if we cannot have the
oral surgeons do this and they do need
to have that added provider you are
looking at a cost of 800 to a thousand
dollars to bring someone else into the
office most of which many of these
children are Medicaid children of which
the parents can't afford the 800 to a
thousand dollars the other option that
surgeons have to do that they could do
is bring the child to the hospital to be
sedated that's increased cost sometimes
upwards of two thousand dollars for
anesthesia there
as well the more concern there is that
the child is then going to go through a
waiting period And if they have a dental
infection that usually can't wait
um
I don't think that the public always
knows how severe a dental infection can
become uh they look at it is there just
baby teeth and these aren't just baby
teeth dental infections can become very
serious in children I'll give you the
name of a child in in the state of
Maryland that died due to a dental
infection several years ago with
Diamante driver he lived in the in
within the Baltimore area and if you
look up that case it was quite quite
frightening because the patient
developed an infection that couldn't be
seen in a timely manner we don't have
that issue here in the state of New
Hampshire because we know that all
children will be seen in a timely manner
it's a very cohesive State the dentist
work very closely with their oral
surgeons and it's never been an issue to
get a child treated in a safe manner so
lift in the exemption completely
um does pose some questions but at a
bare minimum we would you know would
never want to see it lifted for over the
age of eight we know that will make it
even more difficult but under the age of
eight we're willing to agree to that
Amendment as it is right now under the
age of eight most oral surgeons aren't
sedating those patients anyways I don't
think there's a neural surgeon in the
state that would ever it's a data one
year old in their practice you know and
and usually one-year-olds don't need to
be sedated for a tooth infection anyways
those will usually do for other
procedures like they can't nurse well on
the mother is trying to nurse and they
need a procedure done for that so I feel
that you know I know I shouldn't say I
feel I know that this state provides
very very safe care and I will leave it
to your decision as to whether you want
to change this to have an amendment of
eight and under
knowing that we are going to pose an
access to care issue with that and I
have my written test domain that goes
over all those details that I'm happy to
provide to you and I want you also to
feel very comfortable asking us
questions and to ask the experts in the
room the questions as well thank you
thank you are there any questions
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so I'm a little
bit confused doctor uh you did say that
you support representative schuert's
Amendment uh do you have do you have
some problems with the amendment even
though you're supporting it because it I
don't my only concern is I know there
could be an access to care issue because
you may have a six-year-old with an
infected tooth that has high anxiety
Then an oral surgeon could sedate with
very very light sedation they remember
they are not doing deep sedation like a
hospital anesthesiologist does they're
doing light sedation so the oral surgeon
could take that six-year-old do light
sedation have the tooth out in probably
30 seconds or last week the child up
child won't remember anything the child
might be screaming and crying but they
won't remember anything and the
procedure is done within minutes whereas
now that six-year-old needs to go to the
hospital which will delay care cause
extra cost
it's just an it will affect access to
care you know but
it's just a decision you guys have to
make at a bare minimum we would we
wouldn't want to see that happen over
the age of eight though
and somehow the the amendment would
would
force that to happen more often or
at all well what the amendment does it
is it will cause anyone under the age of
eight to have to go into a different
sedation setting the oral surgeon would
have to call a second provider in and if
that child presents you know at two
o'clock on a Tuesday afternoon
where's the oral surgeon going to get
that second anesthesia provider they're
either going to have to call someone and
say we have to postpone this till
tomorrow or if they can come tomorrow I
don't know you know they don't have
people at at their fingertips to just
show up at their office to be the second
provider of anesthesia on an immediate
basis or they have to get us get it
scheduled in the operating room which is
going to be delay of treatment and
increase costs either way it's going to
increase costs more of the concern is
the delay of treatment without with a
dental infection
representative Schmidt the amendment
changes the age from 13 to 8. which
expands the number of
older children who can be treated I get
that part it's just as she indicated
they support the amendment and yet we do
support the amendment because I guess I
know what you're saying like why support
the amendment at all if there's going to
be an access to care issue well we're up
against a big fight and we don't want to
this to to come across as us not wanting
safety for children we absolutely do but
uh so we're willing to take something
may I
say that the amendment lowers the age
for special treatment for children from
13 to 8 which you fully support and it
has some exemptions for younger people
uh including experienced dentists who
have dealt with children in the past
correct so I just to kind of take us
back a step we've never had oral
surgeons have always been under an
exemption that they can treat any age
then recently it came up that it would
be 13 and under and then with you know
the recent questions and Etc that have
happened in the last couple weeks we
said well then we'll go eight and under
but this isn't us that are putting that
forward this was something that was
given to the the dental profession prior
to that they could sedate any age right
and even with this a dentist or an oral
surgeon who has been dealing 20 patients
in two years which is a relatively small
number I would imagine would be exempt
from needing a second
anesthesiologist is that correct correct
okay
so it will
essentially
create
or tend to because they if they can do
it without a second person
they will they'll be able to do so more
easily and more rapidly
correct so the correct
um
essentially you will be allowing
Specialists to in dealing except for the
age under eight except for under eight
especially specifically for eight eight
and under regardless this amendment is
still saying that the oral surgeons
cannot treat eight and under
um ex the exempt from this requirement
if they had personal Administration for
20 patients in the last two years
that's the qualifications for all oral
surgeons
no this is specifically to be exempt
from the requirement to have a dedicated
anesthesia physiologist
present
if you look at the amendment that's line
17 oh sorry I'm I'm sorry if I may I
think Dr Abel who is our oral surgeon
can give you better understanding of his
qualifications as they would be defined
in this new section under representative
schwitz uh Amendment okay but what we
are talking about is strengthening uh
the oral surgeons qualifications for
that exemption as you indicated
represent representative and also
focusing the uh the exemption on
children who are most vulnerable and
that is the eight and under population
all right thank you in that case I I
think we should hear from Dr Abel
except reps down black us uh yeah for
the uh for the dentist uh there who
spoke
um if I understood you correctly you
said there's never been a uh death
related to uh anesthesia related to
Dentistry correct all right and in New
Hampshire in New Hampshire
um so my question is
um
looking for your position on this bill
either with or without the amendment do
you do you actually see if there hasn't
been a problem do you see a need at all
for any of this
no
representative Schmidt well the thing is
I uh I I get it that you know dealing
with small children is a is obviously a
problem uh for Dennis you're you're
they're not only very young they are
very small everything is smaller uh you
know I haven't seen a newborn baby for a
long time but I remember seeing a a uh a
very a preemie that was about the size
of
um you know
one could hold the child in one hand uh
and so so but there is surgery is being
done on on children on babies in utero
in on occasion right uh but also very
very very young yes
say again your question is and my
question is so the the thing is that the
the question of special costs and
special permission and special training
but this is not just limited to
Dentistry there there's surgery is being
performed on very small children in case
of life-threatening Metals medical
situations so uh we wanna
be very careful with regard to the
advice we're getting whether this is
appropriate to do since this is a
medical situation and and and uh so I'm
I think we want to pursue the situation
with your colleague thank you thank you
yes representative I have a question
from Mr Auerbach
um benefit of having a member of the
board that is that has a permit to
administer
general anesthesia and deep sedation
let's just forget the rest of the bill
but if they're I mean that would make
sense to me but I would like your
concurrence
thank you representative I just want to
make sure I'm clear you're asking if do
I see the benefit of an oral surgeon who
is exempt from this from uh a waiver
as they currently exist okay is it
beneficial to have an orange oral
surgeon a member of this board since
they are not currently a member of the
board yeah I'm sorry yes yes
representative uh the the I must uh
confess as I said earlier the uh the
final piece of this bill the way the
lifting of the exemption was not the
board's original design for SB 147. uh
it was actually added on uh in the
legislative process because while the
board of dental examiners was working on
rules pertaining to this very issue and
those rules have taken admittedly quite
some time uh to clarify it's had some
input from from uh General dentists it
has been put from people who are not
subject to the board's rules it's been
uh creating quite a quite a long process
and unfortunately some who were
concerned that it was taking too long or
did not have it going their way went to
to the to the legislature to speed up
the process by lifting proposing to lift
the exemption for oral surgeons that's
where we rested in the Senate uh the
final bill there's actually another bill
SB 91 which was introducing just the
lifting of this bill of this exemption
that was re-referred back to committee
but the amendment was tacked on lifting
the exemption which is why
representative schuett and her wisdom
looked at this worked working with us to
clarify on the areas that we feel are
really of major Focus for patient safety
uh so there's there's a number of
different uh flows that are going on
here uh from our standpoint this could
have been avoided frankly if an oral
surgeon was on the board of dental
examiners there's not been a board a
dental oral surgeon on the board of
dental examiners four years now uh that
individual could have provided a great
deal of insight into the rule making
process and might not have necessitated
this individual or the proponents of SB
91 to come to the legislature
thank you representative Gerhart thank
you madam chair just for clarification's
sake this increased
bureaucratic tape is this going to
increase delays to care
I know every every field saying it's
hard to get people to do everything
right now just labor shortage so with
this increase the time needed to
actually get surgeries done and if so I
know you can't give me an exact but is
this is there something you can speak to
As in that regard I just want to make
sure I thank you representative for your
question I just want to make sure I'm
clear on your question you're asking if
this if the exemption is lifted will
this create more or are you talking
about the general provisions of the SB
just if this was to go into effect
timeline basis is this looking to
increase the weights or inclusive of the
amendment from representative Jewett uh
we feel that
um well right now there is a weightless
there is a weight for this type of care
uh we feel that if you're going to
impose upon oral surgeons who already
have staff dedicated and Dr Abel can
give you a better glimpse of what goes
on in an oral surgeon's operatory
um if this exemption is lifted they're
going to have to bring in another person
is Dr Rosado mentioned earlier you you
can't just pick up the phone and call
somebody and have them come in on a
weekend for an emergency there are going
to be delays
um and you know as Dr Rosado mentioned
if an infection comes it could be an
overnight event where somebody's in the
hospital or something terrible further
happens so we do not want to create any
situation right now that lengthens the
weight for dental care
thank you thank you okay
all right thank you very much Dr Rosado
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee
um my name is Mark Dr Mark Abel I am a
resident of Bedford and I'm an oral
surgeon who practices in Manchester I am
also the most uh recent former chair of
the anesthesia committee for the New
Hampshire Society of oral and
Maxillofacial Surgeons and in years past
I've actually testified in the
legislature before on matters related to
dental office anesthesia
um I'm okay with 90 of SB 147 as
originally written but I'm here today to
express concern about the amendment that
was passed at the last minute in the
Senate uh to remove the exemption
um for oral surgeons to provide deep
sedation anesthesia to patients under
age 13. the amendment's proponents
lacked a full understanding of the
clinical safeguards already in place as
well as the professional and ethical
standards that we must already abide by
to maintain our credentials like nearly
1 000 fellow New Hampshire licensed
Dental colleagues and more than two
dozen oral surgeons practicing in New
Hampshire
um I am committed to the safety of my
patients as an oral surgeon I routinely
am called upon to provide deep sedation
anesthesia for my pediatric patients
membership in our Professional
Organization requires that my intent
that my entire office team is on point
performing regular frequent emergency
training drills and that my facility is
well equipped to rescue children of all
ages from medical emergencies this
mandatory preparation is already further
enforced by the board of dental
examiners
and during the anesthesia permitting
process
furthermore when I am providing sedation
to patients at any age my staff and I
all monitor our patients to make sure
that they remain comfortably and safely
safely asleep under deep sedation
in the development of this legislation
there has been some confusion as to the
age of the children affected I believe
that the amendment offered by
representative schuitt provides Clarity
focusing on the youngest pediatric
patients who are most at risk of an
adverse incident
by nine years of age a child's cardio
respiratory system becomes more similar
to that of older children and adults
so Dr schuett's Amendment ensures that
those dentists who seek an exemption to
administer deep sedation anesthesia to
children ages 8 and under have a record
of frequent experience treating the
youngest of kids
orthodontists frequently request for
oral surgeons to surgically expose
unerupted teeth on children as young as
nine years of age under anesthesia we
are focusing on ages eight and under
because I believe that strengthening the
requirements of the exemption for oral
surgeons to administer anesthesia to
children ages eight and under goes
further to protect patients than
removing the exemption altogether the
latter creates a gap in care for
children aged 9 to 12 years those by
requiring a separate anesthetist when
they are not necessary or by moving
these children to an already
understaffed and oral and overburdened
Hospital environment potentially
increasing costs for patients it is for
these reasons that I ask the committee
to vote that this bill ought to pass as
amended by representative shewitt thank
you and I'm happy to take any of your
questions thank you very much are there
questions representative blackis this is
uh basically the same question I asked
before given that apparent complete safe
safe history in the State uh handling
anesthesia for dental uh
purposes
do you actually see a need for this bill
with or without the proposed amendment
uh yes I see a need for the bill with
the proposed amendment
um
anesthesia permitting is a serious issue
and the oral surgery Community takes the
issue very seriously
we understand that there have been some
sensationalized Adverse Events and uh
some deaths of patients in dental
offices under anesthesia in other states
and we take the knowledge that we've
learned from those experiences from our
colleagues in other states very
seriously
and there is something to be gained by
having these additional requirements for
children ages eight and under we
actually were working with
representative shua to to really improve
the current statutes so that they will
provide the best patient safety for New
Hampshire families
I should
um Dr able would you agree with with my
conclusion that this will
essentially create a group of oral
surgeons who specialize in treating
children
I think that's correct I think there
already are Madam chairs oral surgeons
who
have that as kind of their focus like I
was saying you know the majority of oral
surgeons do treat children ages nine and
over regularly but certainly when you go
into that younger age group eight and
under
um it would make sense to have some sort
of extra requirement that they prove
that they treat this these kids
regularly so that they can have the
exemption
thank you are there other questions
representative true and then Schmidt
thank you madam chair and thank you
doctor for taking my question
um
do you
see 20 patients under eight
no
no I don't
okay follow-up
thank you madam chair
um could you give us an idea of what
would go on
in your office representative
but you speak into your mind thank you
I'm sorry if if you were to be treating
uh a child under eight would you ever
treat a child a day yes so if you were
what's going on in your office yesterday
putting that child under sedation
which would be different than if the
So currently under current statute oral
surgeons are allowed to be Exempted from
their requirement for a separate
anesthetist as long as the board has
created rules that allow for that and
the board of dental examiners has
allowed oral surgeons to be Exempted
so because of that I could bring in a
younger child and provide the anesthesia
myself
um and I am trained to do so
um it's just that I don't do that
regularly uh younger children
proportionally they do have larger
tongues larger tonsils smaller uh noses
there are you know different physiologic
parameters that need to be managed more
carefully in a younger child
so it just I I think even though the
current
you know statute would require would
allow for me to do it I think it makes
sense for patient safety in that eight
and underpopulation just as the chair
was saying to have that extra you know
justification that you do this regularly
that you're a specialist in the area
I think
representative Schmidt you had a
question
thank you so uh I I appreciate your
strong endorsement of Representative
schwart's amendment is this a situation
where we would be better if the
legislature stayed the hell out of it uh
because I you know
I'm wondering whether uh we're mucking
around in areas we know nothing about
I mean to be perfectly honest with you a
representative we've been so grateful
that representative schuett has has
worked with us
um that we've really
you know we've we've helped give our
input into the amendment in such a way
that we think it's very fair and in fact
it it improves patient safety so to tell
you the truth I think this is an area
where the the legislature could be
helpful
um and because the board
um
you know they have had discussions about
adding rules about anesthesia but um
they they had not officially made any
uh rules that were passed regarding it
that I think this legislature could
contribute to in a helpful manner
all right thank you representative me a
follow-up follow-up thank you
so uh it strikes me that
um that there is another body involved
here uh and it seems that the senate had
some
uh
involvement in the in the current state
of the legis this legislation that was
perhaps unfavorable uh uh to the degree
that we change the bill it's going to
have to go back to the Senate even if it
passes the house
um and and uh is this is it same to you
that that this is uh
possibly a fraud situation
well the the meat of this bill is very
helpful uh remember it's it's requiring
that one of the members on the Dental
Board is an anesthesia permit holder
that's very important
um it it creates this facility permit
for dental offices to be permitted to
provide anesthesia in their facility and
it actually also creates an anesthesia
Committee of the Dental Board which
previously had not been legislatively
created so those things are that's the
meat of the bill and that's very
important really the the issue that
needed to be tweaked if you will was
this this issue of the age of pediatric
patients which I feel that we have given
our input on uh very you know with
representative shewitt in a helpful way
one follow-up one final question so how
many people I this is a small state
billion three uh and and uh how many
patients are we dealing I mean I
understand one child that dies is one
child too many but uh but to the degree
we create a structure that's designed
for uh extremely extremely rare
situations is is uh representation
Schmidt I think that question belongs in
the subcommittee and I hope well I'm
glad to hear I'm glad to hear it's going
to subcommitting it's going to be my
question I definitely need to overdraw
my questions
so if we were to leave the bill as is
I'm over here I'm so sorry if we were to
leave the bill as is
but remove
the qualifications just remove H I'm
just I just pretend that that doesn't
that isn't there right now which is the
part that we're talking about
is that something that with the new bore
structure you could put together rules
that wouldn't be amenable or is this a
guard rail that you would want I guess
I'm asking you
be the both of you I mean is it better
to have it done in rule making or do you
do we want to put it in statute
so H I'm talking about H specifically
yeah
H H uh which used to be G
um was created in 2018 uh by a house
bill called hb1577 which I actually
testified it before the Health and Human
Services Committee in both the House and
Senate for and there was a lot of
discussion at that time about whether
children needed uh to have further
regulation from the legislature to
receive anesthesia and dental offices
and
um we've always felt that that g now H
could be improved and so this is an
opportunity to do that I think that the
wording and representative schuett's
amendment is excellent and I think that
would if if the committee and the
legislature adopted that that would be
helpful
thank you thank you thank you this this
will be going to uh I believe
representative Sherwood subcommittee
oh sorry representative schuette yes
we'll be working on this one uh are
there any other questions for Dr Abel
in that case I'll call Dr uh
Tebow
good morning and thank you madam chair
good morning Madam chair and committee
my name is Dr Duane Tebow I'm a nurse
anesthesiologist
my anesthesia practice is one of the
largest providers of dental anesthesia
in New Hampshire we provide anesthesia
to adults and pediatric patients from
Age Two and older
we provide deep sedation to several
hundred patients per year and 44 percent
of our patient population is the patient
population in question Age 2 to 12.
that's approximately 50 patients per
month
I'm also on the board of nursing for the
State of New Hampshire and I'm also one
of four of the dental anesthesia
inspectors for the board of dentistry
and oplc
so I have internet I have very intimate
knowledge of anesthesia for Pediatric
patients Age 2 to 12. I'm here today and
I do not represent the board of
dentistry oplc the Board of Nursing or
the dental anesthesia inspector I'm here
representing myself and the Pediatric
patients that need to have a safer
environment in a dental office in which
they can they receive deep sedation and
general anesthesia for their dental work
in opposition to
dentists providing anesthesia as a
anesthesia provider and the dentist
providing the surgical procedure there
are seven National organizations that
are against this
the American Society of anesthesiology
the Society of pediatric anesthesia
American Society of dental
anesthesiologists American Association
of nurse anesthesiologists Society of
pediatric sedation American Academy of
Pediatrics the American Academy of
Pediatric Dentistry
all of these National organizations
specialize in anesthesia and anesthesia
for Pediatric patients
why are they opposed they are opposed to
have the dentist do the Deep sedation
and general anesthesia for Pediatric
patients because it's not the standard
of care
now in healthcare nowhere in healthcare
does the surgical provider do the Deep
sedation and general anesthesia and
surgery
at the same time for a pediatric patient
nowhere not in the hospitals not in the
surgery centers
so why is it that we allow this to
happen
dental office safety currently in the
state in the dental office in New
Hampshire where deep sedation and
general anesthesia is provided to
Pediatric patients where the dentist is
doing the procedure and the sedation it
is made up of a team that team consists
of the dentist providing the anesthesia
and the surgical procedure as well as
generally two assistants
the issue is not about the the dentist
being able to provide the anesthesia and
their capabilities because they are
qualified to do so the issue really
boils down to their team and how their
team is able to provide emergency care
to a pediatric patient should an
emergency arrive
the assistants that make up this team
that the dentist will heads
are dental assistants their scope or
practice does not allow them to provide
life-saving medications for anesthesia
or reversal medications they cannot drop
the medications they cannot give the
medications they cannot start an
intravenous line they cannot manage an
airway
this makes the dentist the only person
in that room in a pediatric emergency to
care for that patient
the only person
unless the assistant is going to do
something outside their scope of
practice
Senate Bill 147 has amended the original
bill as amended
does places a dedicated anesthesia
provider separate from the dentist which
is the gold standard and the standard of
care hospitals and surgery centers where
deep sedation and general anesthesia is
administered to Pediatric patients
this affords the Pediatric patient a
greater level of safety should an
emergency arise you have two medically
trained individuals the anesthesia
provider and the dentist
that are capable of providing
life-saving measures to that child
and a team approach with two qualified
highly trained providers the dentist and
the separate anesthesia provider will
always be better than a single provider
doing it alone
the amendment that is opposed that has
been proposed by representative Schuler
is not in line with actually the current
language that the board of dentistry has
proposed as rule changing
um
the interesting part is is that this
proposes that a provider of Dentistry
that does less than one pediatric
patient a month is qualified to provide
anesthesia and the surgical procedure to
that patient
We Do 50 in a month
it's a huge difference in experience and
level of exposure to that those kinds of
emergencies
as far as additional costs there will be
no additional costs the current dentist
is paid for both the surgery and the
anesthesia in this current model
when a separate anesthesia is anesthesia
provider is providing the anesthesia
they will be paid for the anesthesia not
the dentist and the dentist will be paid
for the procedure just as in the
hospital or the surgery center it does
not cost the patient anymore just the
dentist will not be paid for the
anesthesia the anesthesia provider will
be paid for the anesthesia
financial burden last year in 2022
Medicaid was billed for 28 cases by
dentists providing both the anesthesia
and procedure ages 2 to 12 according to
Dr Sarah Finney assistant director of
Medicaid services at the March board of
dentistry meeting
multiply that number by 500 percent to
compensate for other anesthesia
companies such as Blue Cross Blue Shield
Delta Etc that's 140 patients per year
with an average anesthesia cost of 850
per child
that total cost per year is a hundred
and nineteen thousand dollars
divide that over the approximate 40
Dental anesthesia providers that are
here in the state of New Hampshire
that's a cost of two thousand nine
hundred and seventy five dollars that is
access to care was another concern that
they have having a separate anesthesia
provider for the surgical provide from
the surgical provider will not create an
access to care barrier the access to
care barrier is the lack of dentists in
New Hampshire taking medicaid
there are only a handful that actually
take Medicaid
if more dentists took Medicaid there
in Senate Bill 147 was amended I would
actually recommend an actual language
change in line 12 Roman numeral 1A we
should it should be changed to the
anesthesia and subcommittee to us to be
established which shall consist of one
dentist member of the board striking who
is a permit and uh to administer
anesthesia
and then for additional dentists should
be struck to have licensing anesthesia
providers and that are currently
permitted to administer anesthesia in a
dental office appointed to the board
this change would allow providers of
anesthesia in the dental office such as
Physicians and myself nurse
anesthesiologists the opportunity to
guide inform and educate the board of
dentistry on non-dental matters related
to Anesthesia
in dental offices from a different
perspective and create a more
well-rounded anesthesia advisory
committee to the board of dentistry
thank you
thank you are there any questions
you'll be available for the subcommittee
uh provided I don't have any pediatric
patients I'm taking care of and if I do
if I can move them yes sir
thank you
doctor thank you for your testimony
today how much of a priority was this
for you to get to the state house today
to to testify
because I notice as you're you're
talking you feel pretty passionate about
this
this has been a long road I have tried
to
get this to the point where we can
provide safer anesthesia care for
Pediatric patients for over a year I go
to every single board of dentistry
meeting or just about every single board
of dentistry meeting I've had the board
of dentistry call me on my personal cell
phone to ask me anesthesia questions
um I'm passionate about this because I
feel that though the oral surgeons and
dental anesthesiologists they are
qualified to give anesthesia that is not
the question in case here
it boils down to what is the safest or a
safer way to provide care and anesthesia
care specifically deep sedation and
general anesthesia to these pediatric
patients I had to move my pediatric
patients today and schedule them for
next week on a day that I normally
wouldn't have them
but the interesting part was when I
asked the dentist
can I schedule these patients are you
able to do this with me the answer was
yes why because she understands as a
pediatric dentist the importance of me
being here today to represent the other
side of the coin that you're not
thank you other questions
all right thank you very much thank you
is there anyone else who we should
testify on Senate Bill 147
. uh
director Courtney how nice to see from
you
thank you madam chair members of the
committee Lindsey Courtney executive
director oplc I'm not going to address
the issue that we've primarily been
discussing today but I did want to
comment on a few technical changes that
I think the committee might want to
consider
the original Bill SB 147 was requested
by the board of dental examiners as a
result of the audit findings that I know
you have have read the audit or some of
the audit and one of the primary issues
that the board would like to address is
the fact that they presently don't
permit the actual dental facilities they
permit the dental providers and
throughout the course of the audit they
have looked at other regulatory models
um they would like to utilize the model
that's utilized in Rhode Island where
they regulate the actual facility as
opposed to the dentist and so that was
really the uh proposal that's contained
in SB 147 I would suggest a couple of
minor modifications however under the
um what I've done to dental examiners
rulemaking Authority ignorance and the
authority to issue permits to dental
facilities
assuming if HB 655 were to pass that
would actually conflict with HB 655 and
we might recommend mend language setting
for it's something like assess or
determine eligibility requirements for
permits to dental facilities the same is
true for
um
page
on the last page and I apologize I don't
have the amendment but it's section five
in line 10 there is a conflict there
with respect to the fee setting
Authority so we would just request
um that rather than have the fees set by
the board that it be established by the
office
would that would be happy to answer any
questions thank you I trust you'll be
able to assist the subcommittee and
including this in any Amendment
certainly thank you representative
blackis thank you um correct me if I'm
wrong but it's my understanding that
regular like doctors offices the
facility is not licensed but if that's
correct then what's the argument for
doing it for a dental facility so it's
actually administratively it's become
um difficult I think to manage because
what they've been doing is issuing
permits to the actual dental providers
which and as part of the permitting
process and Dwayne Tebow can probably
um fill in the blanks if I if I'm not
giving all of the information that's
necessary but as part of the permeating
process they initially go in and do a
facility inspection to determine that
they have the right equipment and that
the hallways you know are sufficiently
wide enough and and every time a
particular dental provider wishes to
receive a permit they have to do that
same facility inspection doesn't really
make sense so they would prefer to have
the facility inspected and permitted so
that qualified providers uh
can administer anesthesia follow-up so
how's that handled in regular doctor's
office I would think there'd be similar
issues or not well the health facilities
are licensed under DHHS medical
practitioners offices are not licensed
but ambulatory centers are so there
there is regulation I do think that the
one area of Health Care Facilities
that's not licensed are practitioners
offices
you know it would seem to me that a
doctor's office is more similar to a
protect practitioner's office than these
other things you're talking about I
agree I think the distinction here that
the board may suggest is that uh you're
only required to be licensed if you
intend to
um utilize anesthesia put somebody under
okay thank you
representative
given the brutal
Dental Board
audit that we read at the very beginning
of this session is now the time to be
considering any new bills regarding this
change
so the board of dental examiners uh as
reflected in the audit does require some
additional legislative changes this is
what they've proposed the oplc is not
taking a position on that but I do think
that there there needs to be legislative
changes with respect to the permitting
process for anesthesia
okay
yeah the the audit definitely had
sections where legislation was required
so we'll have to do we'll have to
cooperate
any other questions
thank you very much thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on Senate bill 147.
all right seeing none I will close the
hearing send it to subcommittee
and open the hearing on Senate Bill 149
and
it's
oh thank you is Senator Rosenwald here
okay Megan Murray representing Senator
uh
Rosenwald
uh good morning
um honorable colleagues of the house uh
Edna
I come before you to introduce and in
support of House Bill excuse me Senate
Bill 149 as amended by the Senate as
Vice chair of the Hillsborough County
delegation the bill this bill was
brought um by Senator Rosenwald and
myself and other uh legislators within
and outside of Hillsborough County at
the request of Hillsborough County
nursing home but do note that other
long-term care facilities have shared
similar concerns regarding these the
needs for such legislation
SB 149 is an effort to help address some
of the skyrocketing costs that we have
been made aware of intestimally before
the county executive body regarding
traveling nursing agencies departments
other than the nursing home are also
experiencing skyrocketing increases in
the cost of care when it comes to
traveling placements
when presented to us the cost of
traveling agencies are nearly double or
uh or more than the cost of those who
are employed directly within the county
even with benefits or other roll-up
costs associated they are still higher
care facilities across New Hampshire are
emerging money to keep up with the
skyrocketing costs associated with some
of these entities in addition to cost
the delicate dance this puts on
negotiating Staffing schedules also
plays a role in how administrators
navigate care Staffing it is true that
most travel care will stay weeks or
months at a time but that said when
Staffing changes out it's still an
interruption to the care modules
you will hear from other folks later who
will talk about the intricacies of what
is before you Hillsborough County uh
nursing home alone has well over 100
person wait list for beds and due to the
Staffing shortages and increased costs
and care to fill the gaps over 50 beds
remain vacant inside the facility due to
fiscal constraints and Staffing
shortages
this backlog alone creates a domino
effect to our larger Hospital networks
when folks are being discharged to more
acute from more acute hospital care into
other areas like nursing homes
this bill will require traveling
agencies to register register with the
office of professional licensure uh and
certification as they are not required
to do so right now and also addresses an
agency contracts and Hospital facilities
ensuring that nursing agencies are not
double booking care providers during the
same shifts or hours at two or more
different facilities at the same time
period of shift and it importantly
ensures that no agency is able to place
an individual Whose license has been
suspended into a care module in New
Hampshire Healthcare facilities
as the vice chair of the Hillsborough
County delegation sb149 offers Clarity
and consistency between providers and
Facilities whose care is delicately
balanced between them this bill makes a
commitment to ensure that there is Fair
competition fees and registered
providers are operating within New
Hampshire so that our care facilities
can continue to utilize a variety of
service providers necessary during
challenging times
thank you
thank you representative has a question
if you can answer it yes um thank you I
will do my best and if not I'll defer to
somebody else at a later time all right
thank you
um
so it's not clear to me how this is
going to help with reducing costs now I
don't I don't get that at all so if you
could help me with that
uh sure I can speak to some of what uh
we have heard before us in Hillsborough
County
um oftentimes there uh seems to be a
competition happening between uh double
booking where an agency will commit a
per person or Personnel to one entity
only to then find it um being rescinded
and going to somebody else at a
representative Gerhart
thank you madam chair so looking in
section well second page
Lines line eight whereas to compel that
facility to bid again for services
already promised
so you sign a contract with these
nursing the nursing agencies right
to provide a service to the the facility
and now they're rescinding they're
renegging on the contract is that
correct
I think somebody behind me might be able
to speak to the specifics of those
because I am not in that position okay
I'm just curious just follow follow up
I'm just curious as to the the penalties
for breaching contract this seems like a
contract issue and it could be handled
that way but anyway the follow-up
another question Madam a different
question different question yes so the
second part on line 10 is a nurse agency
shall not recruit potential employees on
the premises of a health care facility
that just seems kind of like a free
speech issue I don't know how you could
stop somebody from saying hey you want a
job I mean that just seems like a very
Broad
issue
I will say that I think non-compete
clauses are
standard in other places
uh yes but this doesn't say that they'll
have a non-compete Clause that says that
they will not recruit which it strikes
me as being totally unenforceable
you'll have to ask some folks who may be
more aware of some of thank you okay we
will do that other questions
thank you very much for your testimony
good morning Matt good morning Madam
chairman the chair members of the
committee for the record Paula minihan
Senior vice president state government
relations for the New Hampshire Hospital
Association representing all our
hospitals Community Hospitals as well
specialty hospitals we are in support of
Senate Bill 149 and as stated by the
co-sponsor it would establish a process
for nurse staffing agencies to be
registered with the state which would
provide more transparency to all
entities that utilize their services I
will not go over the attachment but I
really wanted to just leave this with
you this summer last summer I should say
we did a labor cost study of our members
and so this is a one-page just
highlights of the study and then a more
complete study that I welcome you to to
review at your at your convenience
it is one it shows that um this outlines
one of our major challenges facing
hospitals today is Workforce and while
the pandemic exacerbated this challenge
um the shortage has increased um with
patient demand and hospitals had to
bring in temporary staff to care for the
growing number of patients who present
with serious illness and in need of
acute Hospital level care but
unfortunately these challenges have just
spiked um in the past several months and
is not likely to diminish so what
happens and I'll kind of skip through my
testimony you could read that at your
leisure but what happens is we now have
this astronomical increase in because of
personnel shortages increasing in
contract labor that is highlighted in
the report that I um I have shared with
you so This truly does threaten the
financial viability of our hospitals
because it is such a astronomical
increase as you can see by the um the
one pager that hospitals have seen at uh
133 percent increase in contracted labor
costs not just labor cost contracted
labor costs they've always had to
contract as you can see from prior years
but now
they had to go out and utilize staffing
agencies and not just for nurses either
I just wanted to clarify we have and the
report does outline all the clinical
Personnel that they need to contract and
non-clinical actually so we do um on
behalf of our hospitals I do strongly
urge you to support this bill and I will
try to answer any questions you may have
thank you are there questions that would
be appropriate for representative leckis
thank you again um I don't see how this
is going to save money
um you maybe you can explain it but I
would think if anything
it could raise costs because you might
have some of the agencies that would
choose not to bother registering and not
doing business in New Hampshire since
there's demand everywhere and with fewer
options uh that might even raise costs
so I don't understand how this is going
to help
um it's just honestly as I stated a very
modest attempt to at least have them
register because we um they're not even
registered in the state at this time so
the original bill was different than the
bill that has been amended and we worked
and agreed with
um all the stakeholders to amend this
bill this is just again a modest
attempt to try to at least have them
register and then as was stated
um
um I think either you or another
individual asked on page two
um starting on line five contracts
between the agencies and the health care
facilities
um shell and then it goes on to say what
it shall not um include because some of
these issues have been raised in the
past again the as far as the hospitals
they have no choice patients need to be
cared for and they must
fill those nursing and clinical
vacancies so they have no choice so this
is again quite a modest approach I know
that there are others here that can talk
about what has passed in other states
that is more significant this is this is
certainly has nothing to do with having
them identify their costs Etc
um again it's it's just we believe in a
positive first step
follow-up follow-up yeah I understand
you believe that but I you know other
than there's some
issues on the Contracting and again as
someone else mentioned I'm wondering if
that could be handled just how you
handle the contracts with the agencies
but I I truly don't see
other than maybe that issue which I
think could be handled another way how
this is going to help and it may very
likely hurt
um so I
if you can you know it's very
specifically how exactly is this going
to reduce costs the rest of it I get
thank you
again it is a an attempt to at least
disclose some information
um and to address our concerns relative
to
um not having a lot of information and
again as outlined on page two it tries
to articulate what um has been a problem
so it may not reduce costs but it's I do
not believe it will re increase costs
and hence why we support this Bill thank
you
thank you representative Gerhart thank
you madam chair
just in your opinion how would you
prevent
nurse agencies from recruiting on
Hospital grounds how do you see that
happening
um so the hospital some hospitals
actually have a policy um to that that
is not allowed when they contract with
an agency but I mean that I think
um representative McGuire's probably why
as far as whether or not that can be
enforced it is just again trying to hone
in and and I guess rein in some of the
concerns and and problems that we have
identified
um with with because
we have to increa we have increased so
dramatically the contracts um but at the
end of the day
um they the con the contract shall not
they will state that they shall not
recruit but if someone were to inquire
certainly that's that's possible the
hospitals some of the policies is
um
um articulate that if you are a current
nurse for instance and you um you cannot
leave the institution work for the
staffing agency then come back as a um
as a contracted nurse potentially at
that institution but it certainly could
go somewhere else but that has again
that is exacerbating our problem
a quick follow-up on it yes please
follow up thank you madam chair so what
would be very broadly what is the due
process
policy procedure for determining if that
was the current would that all be within
the hospitals call they have a little
secret room and they say you were in
violation of this policy or how does
that play out well if I I don't know if
it's a secret room
um but it's a um it's a Hospital's
policy and if you're an employee um just
like any employer you should follow the
employees the employers policies when
you are um hired by them all right thank
you sure representative
so it was um mentioned in the previous
testimony and I see it in this Con in
this uh on page two in line six to nine
so it's possible that in that a travel
agency will book
let's say nurse Jane
at two hospitals
and whichever Hospital pays the most
they will send nurse Jane there and they
will cancel their contract with the
other hospital is that and that could be
basically you're sending the person to
the highest bidder
is that what is that possibly what
they're trying to prevent
um
thank you for the question
representative Grote um I there are
others here that actually
um
sign these contracts and uh run
institutions so I I think they would be
best to answer the question because they
representative Schmidt
question of the chair is this going to a
subcommittee
um at the moment it sure looks like it
looks like an Enlightenment from one of
the half dozen people that haven't
you're forewarned
yes we will we will be seeking
Enlightenment other questions comments
all right thank you very much thank you
good morning honorable chair members of
the committee my name is David Ross for
the record I am the administrator of
Hillsborough County Nursing Home in
Goffstown and I have been a licensed
nursing home administrator for over 30
years
I respectfully request your support of
Senate bill 149.
temporary staffing agencies have long
been a support for health care
facilities and all through my career and
they serve a very specific purpose to
help health care organizations support
safe and appropriate care while we're
working through temporary Workforce
challenges
this bill provides operational standards
by which temporary nurse staff agencies
supporting facilities must abide
the bill initially was focused on
transparency
requiring disclosure of cost paid to
agency workers and comparison with the
charges built to Health Care Facilities
but we've amicably paired this down to
Brass tax establishing standards for
nursing agencies operating in New
Hampshire
the bill no longer requires the
licensing of the staffing agencies but
does require registration with the oplc
it no longer requires that they disclose
costs versus charges because that was
felt to be proprietary information I
will note that all Medicare and Medicaid
license facilities do have to disclose
their own costs through in revenues
annually through a cost reporting
process however
this bill does require that agencies not
leverage their Staffing crisis by taking
personal advantages or booking an
individual at two facilities
um and then bidding up their price so to
be able to send them to the highest
bidder and it prohibits them from
um
recruiting staff at the facilities and
I'm happy to discuss that with you
I'm sure you're tired of hearing of the
workforce crisis we all are no one more
so in healthcare
but what is more tiring is the
unfettered imbalance that the healthcare
staffing agencies have with being able
to charge pricing
that is disregard to any reimbursement
methodology they're taking advantage of
the law of supply and demand and it's
really putting us in a crisis because we
have to balance patient care needs
this bill does not
um
intend to control costs I do not believe
that this bill will reduce costs what
this bill will do is to put some
measures in place to establish some
operating standards initially for health
care agencies that are working in New
Hampshire
there are so many facets here that we
have to work on as a state to be able to
address the workforce crisis
this bill is just one step of many to be
able to help us move along that way I'm
happy to answer any questions that you
have
ah thank you so you you uh
do you contradict the sponsor to the
saying that it's now not now intended to
reduce costs just establish how the this
will these agencies will operate in the
state I don't uh intend to contradict
the sponsor but I do not believe that it
will really have any measure to control
costs the initial bill as presented
really was a measure to help us to
identify costs with the objective to be
able to help control costs
um and we have
um agreed to be able to change some
Provisions in that because there was a
lot of objection to that and at this
point we think that it's just more
appropriate for us and necessary for us
to establish some standards of practice
for the agencies that are operating in
New Hampshire all right thank you if you
could explain to me how
um the non-recruitment Clause is
enforceable
um that if it so in all of our contracts
then and as a as a healthcare agency
provider that they would in order to be
registered in the state they would be
prohibited from that which would require
them to obligate their employees to do
the same
um if an employee is of an agency is
recruiting at a facility then that would
end their service within the
organization and jeopardize their
employment I'm assuming within the
agency in order for them to maintain
registration
thank you other questions representative
Schmidt
thank you madam chair so uh I'm the
chair of the Stratford County nursing
home and I'm wondering at the nursing
home this Trafford County delegation but
I'm concerned about our nursing home and
I'm wondering uh are you all conferring
with one another the administrators to
try to to deal with the situation aside
from legislation very much so very much
so and we are all in support of this
legislation I am here on behalf of the
New Hampshire Association of counties
I'm speaking in support of the nursing
home Affiliates so which does comprise
of all of the nursing homes within the
County's delegation
okay thank you representative
do you find that
in this competing Workforce
situation that you're competing with
other nursing
home facilities or hospitals or anyone
or any health care facility
in this Workforce I am yes the short
answer is yes but I'm also competing
with every other industry that exists we
are losing a cook right now to
um to another entity um to go work for
Amazon
um every entity we are in compete in
competition with yeah
follow-up I I can understand that so
let's just talk about
the traveling nurse yeah so if the
traveling nurse
chooses let's go back to the example
nurse Jane
it has a job as a has a possibilities
booked to work at the Hillsborough
Nursing Facility
but then
you lose that person to another Health
Care Facility what is that Health Care
Facility typically is it a private
Health Care Facility is it another
County facility do you can you can you I
would not know oh okay oh you would not
know I would not know which facility
that they are booked at
um we work with two types of agency
personnel there are individuals that we
consider to be travel nurses that are
booked for an 8 or 13 week schedule with
us say 40 hours a week
um and then there are per diem staff
that we contract with that are for as
needed shifts
so we could book somebody for a shift
for tomorrow evening three to eleven and
then get a call that they're going to be
canceling that shift and we find out
from the individual that they're being
transferred to another facility that's
paying them more
so
um in some cases other facilities
depending on the system that they have
to book their shifts in
um they will get a notice that there's
now an up charge for them to keep that
shift in which case if they want to be
able to keep the shift they've got to
pay more to be able to keep that or they
have to release the shift
um and another facility will take it
hmm yes representative sure thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question
um in the instance that you mentioned
where you have booked someone to come
and then they renege on that and go
elsewhere uh is the alternative that you
then have would be to likely force one
of your current employees to work
overtime which would in fact increase
costs
those are our only recourses is because
we have to maintain safety and
we are already doing that in advance of
booking agency
for my facility we have over 90
positions that are open in our nursing
department we are currently contracted
with 28 individuals from an agency seven
nurses and 21 lnas that only keeps us
safe while we're keeping 50 beds open
our costs this year you know last year
we spent three hundred thousand dollars
on agency in a year now we're spending
that in a month and we are projected to
be close to three million dollars in
agency costs this year
um practices such as up charging
because there may be a covid case in the
facility
up charging because they can enter into
a bidding war those are practices that
should not be permitted because
ultimately all of these costs end up
coming back through the tax base to
County taxpayers the county is
responsible for the non-federal share of
Medicaid costs
so as these costs elevate
it is
completely reasonable to anticipate that
the burden to the taxpayers is going to
grow
[Music]
um
yes indeed any other questions
representative Gerhart thank you madam
chair I had to step out so if I missed
this answer then forgive me but these
contracts seem like they're terribly
written is there's nothing to keep
there's nothing you can write into the
contract to keep these
instances of
price gouging from occurring I mean it's
something to say if you said you're
going to be here at this time you have
to be here at this time or you're going
to be penalized X
correct
um there's two types of individuals I'm
not sure if you were here for that part
of the conversation you did hear that
um so it depends on the type of person
that we're that we're scheduling if we
have someone who's committed to a 40
hour a week schedule they're they're a
travel nurse that are working
um again you know 8 or 13 weeks we don't
see that with them
um where all of a sudden they're booked
Monday through Friday and then on
Thursday they're being canceled to
upcharge to another facility that
wouldn't happen in those contracts when
you're with a per diem contract
um for a day-to-day schedule that's when
you would see that happen when you're
going in to book somebody and suddenly
that shift is being canceled
our alternate our alternative is to not
use them and
um in which case we have to further
reduce our occupancy because we can't
care for patients that we have in the
building so we are really at
the end of the road as far as how much
further can we reduce occupancy
um and be at the mercy of of practices
so this bill really attempts to deal
with some of those poor practices
um from from the agencies and hold them
to a very basic standard of performance
without addressing cost controls on
their part all right thank you
representative blackis thank you this is
actually a question I just thought of
and I'm not sure if you're if you can
answer it but if you can
um so this would be
registration for any nursing agency
whether they contract
with uh government customers or if they
exclusively contract with the private is
true
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I think all accounting nursing homes
have problems funding you know with the
with the nursing agencies
what I don't understand why do those
is it that uh the nurses or lnas that
they're sending only want to work for a
few weeks I mean why aren't they going
to your facility full time
there's a variety of reasons for that
um someone working for an agency gets to
dictate their own schedule they can
determine that they want to work say
just Monday through Friday or they only
want to work Tuesday and Thursday
when we have structures that support
um you know a continuity of care we do
have per diem employees that can work
for us with flexibility so we've create
we've adapted and we've created some of
that flexibility
but what they are not limited to is how
much that they can charge
we are based on our reimbursement
structure so the agencies have the
ability to offer higher pay
um and then come to us and say it's
going to cost you
150 an hour for this nurse to come to
your facility whereas my cell phone
might be able to pay a nurse thirty
dollars an hour
um so
um I don't have a choice if I if I have
no nurse and I have no one else who can
work another shift of overtime because
I've already worked 16 hours in a day
then my option to continue to provide
care to those patients is to book an
agency person
I have nurses that work for us full time
that also work for agencies on the side
and they say I won't pick up a shift
unless I'm getting at least fifty
dollars an hour and the bidding will
start they'll get calls from their
agency saying we get a shift they'll
give you thirty dollars an hour to say I
told you not to call me until it's 50.
and and
and so and that's and that's how it
works so that's why people go is because
it's available
um and because they can earn money
um and I can't blame someone for for
wanting to
um earn more money but we are limited in
a system that is paid for by taxpayers
right as to how much money we can afford
to pay in the system this can't go
unfettered what we're seeing with this
now is that all facilities are
decreasing occupancy
because they there's not enough
Personnel to do this to do this Care on
a continual basis
the average occupancy in New Hampshire
and nursing facilities is now 79 percent
and it used to be in the 90s
we're seeing the backlog in all of the
hospitals where they can't discharge
patients
um and the system is crumbling in upon
itself
while we allow these agencies to
continue to pay more money
um unchecked then we will continue to
see more and more employees that are
gainfully employed full-time leave that
to know that they can go and work for
these temporary agencies on the side and
the system will completely collapse
this bill doesn't stop that and I want
to be clear about that
um we that we wouldn't be able to make
that happen this session
what this bill does is start to take a
look at some of the very basic practices
of those agencies to make sure that we
start to move in the right direction
you're welcome
thank you um I mean I I'm certainly
aware of the financial problem and I
mean I'm I'm in the Hillsborough County
delegation and I pay Hillsboro County
property taxes so I have an interest in
this but um
and so I'd like a solution that actually
works and I'm I on the one hand you say
you can't pay more than some amount
because the reimbursement model on the
other hand you're already paying more
because you're having a contract with
these agencies and I'm wondering if
there's something in the Middle where I
mean those agencies are taking a cut
so unless you believe that the um I'm
just wondering if I'm getting to a
question here but if unless you believe
that the um
the supply of staff is going to increase
enough that this problem is going to go
away and you're going to be able to hire
enough people at the rate you want to
then I don't see this bill doing
anything of any significance to solve
the problem and I'm wondering if Instead
at least for a while if you offered you
know and you're doing some but offer
more money and more
flexibility to the employees to attract
more employees rather than hiring um uh
agency and then and them taking a
significant cut I mean have you
considered that or what are your
thoughts on that we are doing that
um so with our per diem staff we do
offer a higher rate of pay more
flexibility less commitment less
eligibility for any benefits so we're
trying to do those things but we can't
compete with the rates that the agencies
provide
um
I would only say that there's no one
simple answer to this but it's going to
take a lot of small steps to be able to
help get to the right answer
this bill is one of those steps
all right thank you you're welcome
okay thank you representative
Fitzpatrick thank you madam chair uh
I'm married to a nurse she uses the she
uses the term traveling nurses that's
what that's what we're talking about
right
would you say that the Crux of the
yes
uh follow up follow-up do you do you
could you give us a a brief
description of why we have a nursing
shortage
uh versus fitzpat I think that's a tad
beyond the scope of this particular bill
I understand matters thank you okay
thank you
Brooks under Bailey
thank you madam chair
you referred earlier to this law of
supply and demand or
it seems like there's a attempt to sort
of cap wages and wouldn't that cause
shortages of nurses
um this is not an attempt to cap wages
yeah um I want to be clear about that
um some states have kept wages for for
Outside Agency Personnel
um and they're still have many of them
all the time
um
so so I guess if that answers your
thank you madam chair just a quick
question can you tell me
what
happens to Morale on the staff when you
have someone that's making 28 an hour
and you have to go out and hire someone
to come in to do the same job and
they're getting paid 60 an hour
I think you know the answer to that
right is it was morale deteriorates
immensely
um and
um that also addresses the issue of
recruitment when that agency person is
out telling everyone how much they make
um that's that's a big incentive it is
extremely demoralizing and very
frustrating for our staff to be working
16 hours a day aside someone who's
coming in with really no accountability
and making so much more it's it's very
frustrating but this bill doesn't
address that
thank you other questions
thank you very much thank you all very
oh you have to turn it on
thank you madam chair and honorable
members of the committee uh for the
record Brendan Williams I'm the
president of the New Hampshire
Healthcare Association we represent a
long-term care facilities including most
of the state's nursing homes many
assisted living facilities Continuing
Care retirement communities and also the
Cedar Crest Center for children with
disabilities all of these settings are
in support of Senate bill 149.
this is really a transparency and best
practices Bill I've I've heard some
discussion here obviously as to whether
or not it could save costs there are
other states that have gone further just
last year for example Republican
legislatures in Iowa and Missouri
require that agencies disclose all of
their costs to the state what they are
charging facilities and what they are in
turn paying their workers this is not
that bill we are not proposing that that
occur
there were a number of other states that
passed registration acts pertaining to
staffing agencies last year this does
not Place us outside of the norm I think
that any idea that this is somehow going
to discourage Agency use here in New
Hampshire you need not be concerned
about that agencies are not going to
stop doing business here just as they
have not stopped doing business in the
neighboring state of Massachusetts which
actually has a cap on what those
agencies can charge agencies are beaten
down the door to do business in the
state of Massachusetts so but it does um
provide for some transparency we at
least would understand how many of these
agencies are doing business here in the
state of New Hampshire through
registration and registration is not an
onerous thing this is a bill that has
been agreed to with the American
Staffing Association I've talked to a
local staffing agency owner who
is in support of this legislation thinks
it's reasonable thinks that the
practices that this bill would expressly
forbid are practices that no reputable
agency would engage in but we are amidst
a terrible Staffing crisis we have seen
nationally a reduction in the nursing
home Workforce of over uh 300 000
workers since the pandemic began and
that is uh really hitting here at home
and into the void have come staffing
agencies and there was a letter that
roughly 200 members of the U.S House
submitted to the Biden Administration
asking for an FTC investigation into
price gouging by staffing agencies that
letter was bipartisan it was signed by
Freedom caucus members including doctors
gosar and Dr Ronnie Jackson uh Elise
stefanik the number four house
Republican signed on to that letter and
uh you know unfortunately there's been
no action that's occurred at the federal
level and as a consequence we have seen
a number of these registration or
licensure bills in the states
and this bill is very much consistent
with that
from a fiduciary perspective obviously
all of you are members of your county
delegations and County nursing homes are
Contracting with staffing agencies and
we should want a little bit of
transparency associated with those
arrangements we should want a
registration of those staffing agencies
the state itself entered into a 7.6
million dollar contract with a
California staffing agency to staff the
veterans home
they got a relative bargain rate for
licensed nursing assistance paying no
more than
37.44 cents an hour for the services of
an l a
I have a 22 member uh non-profit
catholic-owned Nursing Home in
Manchester only serves nuns and they pay
as much as 43 dollars an hour for the
services in L A and they're writing
those checks to a Dallas Texas address
you know I heard it asked why one can
simply rely upon a breach of contract in
instances where there is double booking
of a person and
as an attorney I should want to see a
lot of litigation but the consequence
short of registration short of some
regulatory regime would be that you
would have to litigate all those cases
you'd have to file a small claim pay a
90 filing fee serve it upon the other
party uh 30-day notice uh serve it out
of state for the most part because these
agencies are based out of state
I'm reasonably sure that the Saint
Joseph
residents in Manchester serving nuns
does not have the wherewithal to
serve parties out of state in Dallas
Texas
um
the Tennessee comptroller at the behest
of that State's a republican legislature
and Governor I did a study on the
explosion of a staffing agency costs in
nursing homes and found that they'd gone
from 9.1 million dollars in cost in 2019
to protect over 100 million dollars in
20 2022
in Sullivan County we have seen the cost
of a nursing home Agency use go from 71
cents per patient day
in 2019 to over 14
per patient day in 2021 that's a two
thousand percent increase
so again uh you know we wanted to reach
further with this legislation uh but as
we know uh the enemy of the good is the
perfect uh legislative process is one of
compromise uh we have compromised with
the American Staffing Association this
is an agreed to Bill that's passed the
Senate and we encourage your support I'd
thank you representative
so I'm thinking that what this
legislation does another word that
you're saying people have said
transparency what it does is it
establishes a Baseline
create a baseline of what's happening in
New Hampshire because we really don't
have a way of doing that other than this
it does and you know I've heard some
very good questions you know for example
somebody said boy these are really bad
contracts right well you know these are
contracts of adhesion effectively I mean
there's an imbalance of power here your
provider you need the services of an
agency you're not going to be able to
negotiate that boilerplate contract I've
got to fill a Friday night shift in
order to be able to serve my residents
or I'm going to get cited by the state
uh applying Federal survey standards
what am I going to do
I'm going to take whatever contract I
get and those are the circumstances that
facilities find themselves in
there was also a question about uh you
know the enforceability of
non-recruitment on the premises uh
you know I've never gone into a Market
Basket and seen an application table for
work at Shaw's the First Amendment does
not confer the right to do business on
another business's premises and so I
think this is entirely consistent with
what other states have done
okay thank you for that point other
questions
seeing none
look we'll uh
thank you madam chair my name is Gary
pahoon
um
I'm here representing the New Hampshire
Association of Residential Care Homes
which is the Statewide Organization for
residential care and assisted living
homes
um I shouldn't say the as Brendan said
here also represents some assisted
living homes but we represent more
um
what I have handed out is a letter
written by Sarah NATO
who is the owner administrator of
Carriage Hill in Madbury
and I hand this out because I think it
gives some insight on the perspective of
the plight of these smaller organization
or the small smaller home in this crisis
which is only exacerbated by the
staffing agencies Sarah had hoped to be
here today herself to address you but
she was unable to come so she asked me
to come in her Stead
[Music]
um
if you look at the letter you'll see
that many of the things that are in the
bill that are addressed as abuses in the
bill have happened to her and to her
residents at Carriage Hill
um she has paid 20 to 40 dollars an hour
surcharge for covet outbreaks
um recently within the last three weeks
she has been charged a four dollar per
hour service charge for late booking or
last minute booking uh which is defined
as any booking less than 12 hours before
the shift
neither of these are in neither of these
surcharges or in her contract
um as Brendan pointed out these are
adherence contracts these aren't
negotiated contracts
the contract is presented to you and you
sign it or not if you don't sign it you
don't get the services if you do sign it
you're pretty much Bound by it
when they break even their adherence
contract your only recourse really is to
sue them and as Sarah will point out in
her letter she has neither the time nor
the money attempting to run her 24-bed
facility to take on any of the staffing
agencies
so
she has also lost to employees in the
last year to recruitment from staffing
agencies and she's had to bid on several
occasions
at the last minute for staff because
she's she's con the way that works is
that she's contacted by the agency and
said okay we've committed an aid to you
for the the 11 to 7 shift tonight
however there's another party who's
um
the bonus is she understands in most
instances does not go to the agency it
goes to the
staff member who was sent okay and the
the agency uses that incentive to retain
and recruit staff so it's another
Advantage they have over uh over the the
home that would normally employ them
Sarah points out that in the last year
she spent sixty thousand dollars over
what she would normally have spent for
staff
um by using agencies in others that's
not sixty thousand dollars of the agency
she's actually spent I guess eighty or
ninety thousand dollars with agencies
but that sixty thousand dollars more
than she would normally have spent if
um Sarah's room home is relatively small
over the last few days I've talked to a
number member a number of our members
who have used staffing agencies I talked
to a home in Nashua that is budgeted has
budgeted one million dollars for
staffing agencies this year
on average they are uh Hiring Agency
staff for two to three hundred hours per
week
um again before the pandemic they
occasionally used
staffing agencies but only very
occasionally and in nothing like this
one of the uh when I spoke to that
particular administrator one of her
complaints
is that she has had applicants come in
to apply to work at her facility
after doing a criminal record check
and she found that they were employable
okay if they had a large a long criminal
record with felonies by state rule
Hep 804 and Hep 805 she cannot hire
someone with a with a felony
nor can she hire someone who appears on
the beas registry which is a registry of
people who have founded complaints
against them of abuse neglect or
exploitation
all right so these people have come to
her she has turned them away and two
weeks later they come to her as a
representative of the agency
okay
the bill in its current form on page
oops excuse me on the second page
uh 15 15 and 16.
says nurse agencies may not facilitate
the placement of any licensed
professional with a license that is
suspended I would like to suggest that
we make an addition to that line I've
talked to uh about this with a sponsor
of the bill and a couple of the other
stakeholders
the issue here is that Residential Care
Homes and employ a fair amount of staff
that is not licensed
um
they're called pcas or caregivers
they're called many different things but
under the licensing rules they are not
required necessarily to have licensing
staffs depending on what their function
is so many of the basic caregivers are
not licensed
I would suggest that we might add to
this something along the lines of let me
see if I can read my own writing
um nor will they facilitate the
placement of an individual who is not
employable under the DHHS administrative
rules for the setting in which they will
work
okay in other words if they are on the
beas registry or they have committed a
felony
um
I spent as I said the last few days
talking to people my general experiences
have been that once I called someone I
was on the phone for an hour
the a lot of people have a lot of
venting to do over these issues
um and again I don't know if it's going
to lower costs it will in some instances
if it can eliminate the bidding for this
for an individual for the same shift
have some moderation on costs I would
think and I don't see how it's
necessarily going to raise costs because
nothing in this is particularly onerous
for the agencies so again uh as a
representative of the New Hampshire
Association Residential Care Homes I
thank you are there questions
representative Schmidt oh yeah thank you
madam chair I'm sorry just with with
managing all the papers
I was distracted at the moment when you
said your name I'm Gary Cohen
my name is Gary Cajon I'm representing
New Hampshire Arch well I knew I
recognized you but okay that for my age
I'm lucky if I find it my way here in
the mornings
okay uh for 37 years I owned an operated
friendship manner
um in New Ipswich we closed last May
due to short staffing we couldn't staff
okay all right thank you Mr Capone
other uh
LaCroix
thank you madam chair Vice chair and
distinguished members my name is Jeffrey
Lacroix and I'm here today to testify in
support of sb149 relative to nurse
agencies and a free market system the
consumer selects their vendor based on a
variety of options including price
demand and availability prior to covid
although High rates for contract staff
were more reasonable however the race
for the same contracts doubled and at
times tripled because of Hazard pay
typically agency staff are individuals
from another state looking to make a
higher wage than they would receive as a
permanent staff member this is money
leaving and not benefiting New Hampshire
residents we were obligated to protect
the resident's safety and well-being and
to do so we have to ensure we know
exactly who these caregivers are and if
they are and if they have markings on
their license sometimes a challenge with
out-of-state workers
these agencies identified and leveraged
an opportunity to financially benefit on
the backs of nursing homes during the
federal state of emergency each
increasing their hourly rate and
introduction to hazardous pay all of
which the agencies Justified due to
demand the potential for staff to
acquire covid and housing difficulties
initially we continued with our old
rates but found ourselves without agency
staff because the agency staff became
and continued to become entitled to
these inflated rates we experienced
multiple situations in which we place an
agency staff member on the schedule for
a 13-week contract only to be told a few
days before the start that there was a
cancellation because they were given
another higher at a higher rate creating
a bidding war which is what you've been
hearing
within the first 11 months of the fiscal
year my building has spent the following
on agency Staffing one million three
hundred and eighty thousand three
hundred fifty one on lnas
996 968 on LPNs and 149 170 on RNs for a
total of over 2.5 million dollars
we have become subject to the
normalization of these inflated rates
and at times duplicitous acts none of
which are acceptable in a free market
system
with a census of over 60 Medicaid and
now delays on the Medicaid approval
process we have significant Interruption
of payment and cash flow concerns and we
find ourselves struggling to offer the
programming our residents rightfully
deserved
the staffing agencies have collectively
cornered the market resulting in a
financially unseenable unsustainable
solution to our staffing crisis this is
not an acceptable practice and a free
market system particularly since
reimbursement is provided from the
taxpayers through Medicare and Medicaid
I thank you for your time and
deliberation on these important matters
and affecting our Health Care system and
stand ready to answer any questions that
I don't see any at the moment thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on Senate bill 149.
save yourself some bother and put the
thank you madam chair members of the
committee Lindsey Courtney executive
director oplc oplc does not take a
position on this bill but I would
suggest if this bill does move forward
that 326 B is not the appropriate
placement for this bill
326b is the board of nursing practice
Act and the bill as amended appears to
Grant authority to the office and not to
the Board of Nursing and so we think
greater Clarity is needed and that
perhaps it needs to be placed elsewhere
or in its own statutory provision
if uh Warren worn out our questions but
oh representative black history I think
one brief brief one um so it appears
when we heard that uh there are nurses
being placed by the staffing agency in
New Hampshire who
um aren't licensable I guess and what's
the legal status of that I mean how is
it they're able to practice here
at all and um
and what would oplc do if they learned
they were informed that there was
somebody acting as a nurse here who um
you know was on that list or convicted
of felonies or whatever
I mean how are they here through the
nursing compact something else
um I'm not sure representative I think
that that
those prohibitions may fall under the
DHHS rules and not the licensure rules
because we certainly would check for
qualifications at licensure renewal but
there are unlicensed Personnel that work
in facilities if the registration were
to move forward like any sort of
registration licensure certification
requirement if there was a violation
that would be considered discipline and
you could take a number of actions to
include reprimand find up to revocation
of the ability to practice
follow up follow up yep but just as the
law stands today you know I understand
they have staff that aren't aren't
nurses and aren't we don't license but
if it is somebody who's licensed by New
Hampshire uh a nurse in Illinois or
whatever
um you know what could or would oplc do
if let's say the facility notified him
that the agency had placed somebody like
that here
I think that would probably be a
violation of the registration
requirements um better set forth in this
and we even treat it in that manner a
quick follow-up I meant you know if
right now today without this bill at all
oh as it stands now well see licensure
and health facilities have different
um criteria when it comes to for example
criminal convictions we don't have a
general prohibition on felony
convictions with the exception of RN in
the nurse compact licensure act so it
could be that so as I understood it I
heard that Health Facilities which is
DHHS has a general prohibition on felony
convictions from a licensure standpoint
we don't under 332g we have to engage in
analysis as to whether or not somebody
is more likely to offend with the
license than without it so it could be
that you have a license but you aren't
authorized to work in a DHHS facility
and and briefly you follow up and then
um you know the registration habits
people being placed who have licensed or
suspended but even without this I mean
if oplc was notified of it wouldn't that
be a problem for somebody who New
Hampshire would require licensing if
they have a suspended license oh
certainly yes if they're practicing
without a license yes we would take
action thank you all right thank you yes
and it appears we aren't familiar with
the HHS requirements but they are
rigorous
all right I believe this will be going
to representative blackis's subcommittee
I haven't closed the hearing yet I'm
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for indulging me at this hour
um my name is Bruce Berkey I'm with C
Infinity Capital group here in town and
we represent Interim HealthCare which is
a manchester-based
healthcare staffing
organization and business as well as the
American Staffing Association you heard
both of those entities referenced during
earlier testimony and I was not
intending to testify today in fact I
didn't even bring my orange badge I
wasn't intending to testify so I
apologize
um but I I uh we do support this current
language that's before you today we did
not support the bill as introduced over
in the Senate because it was very
invasive of private business practices
um a registration process that is in
Senate Bill 149 now is appropriate
some of the business practices that are
discussed on page two are appropriate
um but going beyond that as some of the
previous speakers suggested with
you know this being a first step or this
I think going beyond what you have
before you today is
invading having state government take
steps into private business activities
that are not appropriate
that's why we oppose the original bill
on the Senate side
and that's why we're okay with it as it
is before you today
I'd be happy to try and address any
questions
thank you
don't see any immediate questions but
I'm sure the subcommittee would be
delighted to talk with you I will be
there very good all right as long as
it's not next Thursday or Friday
next Thursday we're kind of busy okay
yes you are that's right
all right thank you is there anyone else
who wishes to testify on Senate bill
149.
not seeing anyone I'm going to close the
public hearing this is going to
foreign
all right representative blackis since
you're there oh no sorry never mind uh
Senator Whitley will introduce
thank you madam chair good afternoon
members of the committee for the record
my name is Becky Whitley I'm honored to
serve Senate District 15 which includes
the wonderful communities of Beau
Concord Penacook and Hopkinton so today
I'm proud to introduce Senate Bill 126
and this bill will allow broader access
to treatment for residents at the New
Hampshire Department of Corrections so I
think this committee is well aware that
access to treatment in particular access
to mental health treatment is limited
for all Granite Staters but compounded
with additional challenges in a
correctional setting the crisis is even
more acute so I introduced this bill at
the request of the Department of
Corrections and I really do commend them
for their commitment to ensuring that
their residents get adequate treatment
and in a timely way
um
uh I am happy to take any questions but
the Department of Corrections is here to
answer any more specific questions I
think they they also see it as a safety
issue we do know that anytime that there
is a transport that that's a safety
issue and I think access to Telehealth
would
um allow less of those transfers for
certain residents
um this bill enjoyed broad support in
the Senate unanimous out of committee
um you know I think it may have been
even on the consent calendar
um there was a minor amendment in the
Senate just to ensure that whoever is
providing mental health treatment
um not only you know certified license
but also is is in good standing in their
state so with that I asked for the
committee's support of Senate Bill 126
and happy to take any questions
oh
thank you Senator are there any
questions
excellent job no questions easy on me
today thank you I'm going to go back to
my session all right
good afternoon Madam chair and honorable
members of the committee for the record
my name is Helen Hanks I'm the
commissioner of the Department of
Corrections I appreciate Senator Whitley
and the other sponsors of this bill
supporting it to this path forward our
goal is is what would appear simple for
Corrections we know and are proud of Our
obligation and requirement to provide
constitutionally appropriate access to
health care services and we see this as
an opportunity both as a safety net but
as a responsibility to acknowledge that
there are Specialties across the country
in addition to General needs in
Psychiatry primarily but it's not
exclusive to those areas of service
where we have in the past had to
appropriately pay a national expert to
fly to the state of New Hampshire engage
in on-site treatment services and and
time technology has progressed we really
want to make sure that we can be nimble
when those unique instances surface but
also be responsive on a regular basis
because we know nationally and within
our our own State recruiting psychiatric
providers and other health care
providers to work specifically in a
correction setting is a challenge when
we're having a struggle to do those in
community settings so we really want to
be able to maximize both our existing
contract we will always have a
contracted Health Care Service partner
and they have other licensed
professionals across the country
providing Correctional service I think
it is unrealistic to expect a national
partner to get all of their licensed
providers licensed in all of the states
in which they're contracted and this is
not intended to be a full-time resource
it's really a gap Gap when we don't have
the Staffing and or we need a national
expert I've provided testimony I know
you will read through it and look at
those resources I will not read it to
you but those are the primary issues
we're looking looking to solve in this
piece of legislation and with that I
certainly Avail myself to any questions
of the committee thank you commissioner
I have a question yes uh you mentioned
that this only addresses
Physicians and Physicians assistants
what about other Mental Health
Counselors
right it wouldn't include psychologists
or or social workers or latex or
whomever
no we were looking specifically at the
psychiatric provider licensed positions
in that in that realm we certainly could
consider psychiatric nurse practitioners
but our hardest Gap to Phil had been a
psychiatrist or again National experts
that are usually psychiatrists
but we would not be offended by
increasing the opportunity to other
psychiatric providers so the
all right find as long as you're aware
that's uh that's my question other
questions
representative Gerhart
Madam chair
are with the services that you need to
be filled are these mandated or this is
inmates coming to you for voluntary
Psychiatric Services or is this part of
their sentence
that's a great question uh
representative treatment services are
not
um forced so these are services that
we've assessed individuals for treatment
needs and then we provide the providers
to help them with their treatment needs
then follow up so there's no penalty for
not participating
no sir that would be unconstitutional
thank you
we would not approve of that any other
questions
okay well thank you very much
commissioner thank you and thank you for
your service to the state everyone
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
David cuzzy with the Prospect Hill
strategies here in town uh before you
today on behalf of the New Hampshire
Society of physician assistance I did
submit a letter uh online but I'm happy
to resubmit if that didn't get through
to you the Pas don't have any position
on the bill but uh and I think you'll
sense a common theme uh usually I'm
before if it's this committee or HHS
because the Pas have been either
inadvertently excluded from a bill or
the and as in the case here they've
there the profession has been either
incorrectly spelled or or referenced and
and so
um along those lines uh of course you
all know that Pas are physician
assistants they're not assistants to
Physicians uh and so I'm hoping that
um an amendment could be brought for to
just simply correct a few misspellings
and I'm happy to point them out if if
that's okay and I did note them in the
uh in the in the letter that we sent
over uh first of all just on a
the uh I guess the cover of the bill if
you will uh the description of the ACT
uh relative to uh you'll notice uh where
it says a relative to licensure a
physician and Physicians assistants that
asks at the end of physician should be
deleted it should just say physician
assistance
in the analysis on that same page the
same mistake is made licensure
Physicians and Physicians assistants and
it should say physician assistant
um
also uh
again in the bill itself the description
of the act at the very top the same
mistake there's an S at the end of
physician and physician assistance
um
and then in the bill on line 12
for Physicians where it should be
physician assistants
bless you madam chair
I note though that they the the
appropriate references made on lines
eight and ten of the bill where it has
physician and physician assistant or
physician assistant so that that is the
correct way I'd also note the point out
on the fiscal note where it just has the
description of the bill uh it has that
same mistake where it says where it has
the S at the uh at the end of Physicians
sir I'm sure that that the title and the
description were simply cut and paste
right no I'm just just referencing it so
that that's all I had I hope that if you
know that can be corrected we'd be happy
uh and that is all I had Madam chair
foreign
is there anyone else who wishes to
all right seeing none I would close the
and chair is the corrections that the
previous speaker mentioned could that be
done as an enrolled Amendment if we note
it to uh it certainly could be yes thank
you
okay
all right uh represent grotta has a
motion I make a motion for auto pass on
House Bill 126 FN I'll second it
all right uh do you wish to speak to
your motion this it seems to be a common
sense
um
Bill and um I think it will help those
in the uh New Hampshire Department of
Corrections
all right regardless yeah I second that
I mean I would pretty much support this
for everybody but doing it in the prison
makes a lot of sense
thank you okay
does anyone else have a comment question
discussion
representative true
thank you madam chair and well we've
only well we've got people missing I'll
I'll show everyone how stupid and
I don't I didn't I wasn't going to ask
it in one of uh people testifying
what position assistant would you need
to contact outside of the State of New
Hampshire
perhaps there is a specialized
psychiatric
physician assistant who is
domestic violence or sexual predation
which are some of the reasons that
to be a specialist yeah
yeah and
um
but as you point out
a psychiatrist is in a is in a position
a psychiatrist is a physician a
psychologist is not a physician but a
psychiatrist is there's a doctor okay
yeah
okay
okay a couple more back
um
okay the emotion is ought to pass on
Senate Bill 126 by representative Broda
and the clerk can call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
yes
representative Gerhard yes
clerk votes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt
okay not when the question was put you
were here when the question was put
yes you were
yeah
thank you representative Schmidt
representative shewitt yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes
and the chair yes
14 yay zero name
action passes fourteen to zero is there
any
objection to consent
all right seeing none we'll put this on
consent and uh make a note to the
uh enrolled bills committee on the
spelling
and we now have half an hour so we can
all go get dessert
foreign
thank you everybody it's 2 15 I would
like to open the public hearing on sb44
and uh welcome Senator Carson
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh I am not Senator Carson uh
I am a grant bossy deputy chief staff
for the New Hampshire Senate pinch
hitting for Senator Carson the lead
sponsor of Senate Bill 44 as you know
today is our crossover day in the Senate
and the senator is currently I believe
in a floor debate on your constitutional
amendment on the edge of Judges so she
could ask me to fill in for her today
last year 355 Granite Staters died due
to drug overdose one of the many
challenges in combating this wave of
addiction is The Chronic Workforce
shortage of drug and alcohol use
professionals sb44 would expand the
licensing requirements for master
licensed alcohol and drug counselors
under RSA 330 to include mental health
and mental health disorders it would
also expand the pool of Bachelor level
students who qualify for licensure by
allowing criminal justice Majors to more
easily pursue a career in treatment
removing the subjective process
currently in place through the licensed
alcohol and drug counselor board
the struggles of mental health disorders
and substance use disorder often overlap
sp-44 would enable Master's level
substance abuse counselors to continue
to treat patients should the primary
diagnosis change from mental health or
substance use or back
Senator Carson thanks for your
consideration and ask for your support
of Senate Bill 44. thank you very much
thank you
any questions
see none thank you for your testimony
chair McGuire plans on sending this to
uh subcommittee which I'll be chairing
and so I'm hoping you or the senator or
you or somebody
um would would be able to work with us
whenever that gets scheduled I'll pass
that message along okay thank you thank
you
thank you
good afternoon Representatives my name
is Jake Berry I'm the vice president of
policy at new Futures as many of you
know we're a nonpartisan non-profit
Health policy and advocacy organization
we've been working for more than 25
years to address issues related to
alcohol and substance use and mental
health issues in our state uh I don't
want to repeat too much of what Mr bossy
said here this afternoon but I do want
to emphasize new Futures strong support
for this bill I know I don't need to
tell any of you uh that for years
Workforce shortages have been one of the
biggest barriers to overcoming our
state's addiction crisis throughout our
substance use system uh the lack of
counselors and other professionals make
it impossible for many individuals and
families to access the treatment they
need
SB 44 alone won't solve all of our
Workforce issues but it will take
several important steps to bring more
people into the workforce and help help
get treatment to more people in need
first as you heard Mr bossy say this
will allow mastered license and alcohol
drug counselors to treat mental health
cases as well as substance use and
co-occurring disorders there's a great
deal of overlap as you'll hear this
afternoon in Education and Training
between the substance use and mental
health treatment fields and Master's
levels Mental Health Counselors are
currently allowed to treat substance use
cases so we're just trying to even the
playing field to some extent this would
align these scopes of practice and allow
masters of level substance use
counselors to treat more people in need
to continue and to continue to treat
established patients even as their
primary diagnosis changes between
substance use and mental health and
mental health as it often does
uh secondly sb44 would bring us one step
closer to Reciprocity for our recover
for our recovery Workforce by aligning
New Hampshire's continuing education
requirements for Certified Recovery
support workers uh with those set by the
international credentialing
organizations that sets these national
standards by allowing these requirements
this would set the table for the late
act board to pursue Reciprocity for
crsws should so choose so that's a basic
overview of what this bill does as you
can see from the sign-in list we have a
broad Coalition of supporters across the
substance use Mental Health and Health
Care Spectrum including the National
Association of Social Workers Nami New
Hampshire the medical society the
hospital Association by state Primary
Care Association and others uh simply
put we believe this will create greater
flexibility and efficiency in licensing
and to help get treatment to more people
in need
um I do it sounds like this will be
going to a subcommittee I do have a
draft language for a very very minor
Amendment uh there there are three
pieces the amendment and I'm happy to
share this with you all uh two of them
are just chain uh are just wording
changes to clarify definitions uh one of
one of them would remove the
um the criminal justice degree provision
that was included in there we've heard
over recent weeks some questions about
whether the criminal justice curriculum
aligns fully with uh
um with substance use training and so
while we thought that uh maybe taking
that out for now and working through
that might be a good way to go
um so with that I'm happy to take any
questions but I know that uh my
colleagues in back of you can speak in
more detail to any of this than I can
but I'm happy to take questions yes
representative thank you Mr Berry this
the amendment that you're speaking about
um is it the one that you sent to me it
is yes okay I have distributed it
throughout this committee wonderful
thank you representative very much
yes representative yeah just um one
thing so the changes in the licensing
requirement to align it with the
The Wider standards um I'd have to go
back on the bill but just briefly do
they increase the amount of training
required uh reduce it what kind of
changes for the 16th for that we're
talking about for the continuing
education hours required for uh crsw
recertification it increases it if I'm
recalling this right from 16 to 24. my
understanding is that many of these
professionals are already engaging in 24
hours this shouldn't create any more of
a hurdle for them but by aligning it
with the national requirement again it
would make us more eligible for
reciprocity follow up you know that's in
part 10 I see that but in part nine
section 9 it's talking about the initial
licensing and so what's the uh
the substance and the key points of the
changes there
uh I apologize page three this is line
nine you know if you don't mind we have
some uh folks from the treatment
community in back of us who might be
able to speak more directly than I can
if you don't mind any other questions
thank you very much for your testimony
I apologize ahead of time Diane
castanucci
thank you Mr chair and the committee my
name is Diane Castrucci I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
alcohol and drug abuse Counselors
Association where I've been for the past
19 years I'm also a master licensed
alcohol and drug counselor
um
I'd like to try to answer representative
Lexus
Lexus is his question first and that
tell me if I'm interpreting this
correctly
does this change the number of Education
hours required for someone to get an m
laidac
um ours or or any of the requirements I
mean my my concern if you can address it
is that you know there's already a
shortage of people doing it and if there
was a substantial increase in the
requirement then you know it might make
that problem worse but you may like this
answer then it does not increase the
requirements what it does is it
acknowledges the education that they
already have and expands the scope of
practice so that when they start seeing
a client that has co-occurring disorders
historically what uh what's happened
what happens now is when substance use
is no longer
um
when substitutes become stable
and they're primarily treating
um a mental health disorder other than
substance use by itself
the the M latex has to transfer someone
to a different clinician
and so for example there are some mental
health conditions that are chronic
long-term conditions
um
the one that's easiest for me to say is
schizophrenia but you can go you know
depression anxiety you know all of these
different things they can be complicated
with substance use
but once you take care of that
complication the law currently says that
M latex can no longer treat those other
disorders when they're by themselves
so
this change acknowledges that
the M latex does know how to treat
mental health disorders they have been
treating mental health disorders because
they're treating those that are
Complicated by addiction
and it doesn't mean they know any less
about those mental health disorders when
addiction is no longer present okay
follow up
so the training the Emily decks have had
covers a broad range of mental health
disorders not just the ones related to
drug alcohol use absolutely they have
oftentimes the exact same college
education
60 credit master's degrees
the language for the education that
there need that they need is mirrored by
what is also needed within the other
Master's level clinicians when we were
first proposing this bill in the house
um
the community Behavioral Health
Association had had issue with a piece
of it and that was that it included
uh Human Service degrees
and in looking at that language
um the history of that was examined and
Human Service was included because of a
degree that existed at a time
um I think it was 2010 or 2008 when the
when the bill was first created
and that program no longer exists so
removing Human Service as a required
degree for the m laidac
maintains that the education is
equivalent to what the different Mental
did you want to give other testimony as
well
uh yes another question can you write
let's say that you have a patient that
is that has an underlying mental health
condition that's Complicated by
drug abuse and you work with that person
you develop the relationship with that
person and you're able to work through
with them
their drug abuse issue
which may or may not be gone forever
and then if once that person is free of
the abuse then they are you are required
to send them somewhere else where they
have to re-establish another
relationship and okay that's what I
thought thank you
yeah the the biggest problem is as
people who need counseling services get
lost because
establishing a relationship with a
counselor is a very personal and private
thing and once you find someone that
you're working with and it works well
and you're able to like adequately
stabilize the addiction
it's it's really a shame to have to say
okay now you have to go work with
someone else for the other parts of the
mental health condition
representative like us thank you um I
mean that that makes complete sense uh
my question is
um you know if they have similar
training why is there a separate M ladak
or the other mental health professionals
do they have some extra specific
training related to drug and alcohol
abuse is that the main difference there
is additional training and one of the
other people scheduled to speak has been
the primary substance use advocate for
all of the building of this profession
and so she will probably add to that
thank you Jackie
when
it
substance use people could only treat
substance use people they couldn't treat
people with other mental health
disorders at all
and it was back then it was considered
substance abuse it wasn't considered a
substance use disorder like language has
when the M late deck was created
because the rule had always been that an
Emily That Couldn't treat
a mental health disorder
other than substance use
a compromise was made that they would
only treat within co-occurring and that
was an acceptable compromise now the
education the testing all of that has
become co-occurring and so
the the person who
was trained to be a substance use
counselor many years ago might not have
had the same expertise as someone does
now
does that help answer it I'm just quick
follow-up follow-up just uh give me a
simple answer so my understanding and
correct me if I'm wrong is that that
basically M ladak has the same training
as more General mental health people but
they also have an additional extra
specialized training for drug and
alcohol abuse correct treatment and so
it's kind of a a specialty of the mental
health area more than a completely
separate thing is that correct yeah
essentially
um the way without this change
in order for a
an M laid act to prove that they know
how to treat other mental health
disorders and to be able to do that when
the substance use disappears they had to
get two licenses
okay and so not only do you have the
extra education to be able to treat
substance use you had to prove
above and beyond everything else that
you could do that by getting another
license okay thank you
unless you have something else to share
you're all set um
I would encourage the committee I
I know that the study committee is going
to have a lot involved and I plan and
want to be part of every part of the
study committee
but I would encourage you to even
consider passing this without putting it
in the study committee because of how
vital it is for client care
let me um clarify that it's not
aesthetic memory it's a subcommittee a
subcommittee it's a committee's
responsibility is to get something
tightened up and neatened up so that so
that we can vote on it so we will be
voting on it don't worry we're not gonna
like don't totally my misunderstanding
Thank you
yeah so I mean what a subset of us that
people here will meet and uh go over in
more detail
and spend a little more time on it and
if you're available be great having you
uh we have we'll figure out when to
schedule it but uh to provide input on
it and go over it in more detail and and
see if there needs to be any changes or
not and then come back to the full
committee but full committee will vote
on this thank you thank you all right
thank you
one out of two I gotta get something
laughs
yes good afternoon uh thank you Mr chair
uh and members of the committee uh I
appreciate the time to speak with you
today
um I guess I would like to before making
any of my own comments address one of uh
representative lakas's Lucas I'm trying
uh
um questions and that was about is
um is the m ladak more of a specialty of
mental health uh than a license onto its
own and my answer is it is not a
specialty of mental health so there is a
long history in this profession of
growing up through a culture of
substance use disorder and understanding
and building on the understanding of how
substance use disorder is not only a
complication of Mental Illness but also
an illness all on its own and it's not
just that uh the folks who have M latex
treat substance use disorder along with
mental health but they understand they
are trained in the integrated care of
how to be able to differentially
diagnose when a mental illness is uh
stands on its own and when their mental
illness is caused by the symptoms of
mental illness are not really mental
illness at all but really a symptom of
ongoing use they are trained in how to
treat the two disorders together
historically what has happened is you
treat the mental illness when it comes
up you treat the substance use disorder
when it presents and what uh what the M
late act has been trained to do is know
how to treat both even when not one is
not active to prevent it from relapsing
in the future so it is really its own
kind of culture and own profession and
what the laidac board has done is
created a Workforce letter we we have
such a Workforce shortage in this in
this state and it has created a
Workforce ladder whereby you can start
as a a peer a peer support person a crsw
and build on the knowledge and the
education that you gain to get your laid
act and build on the knowledge and the
education that you gain and it all
counts towards your M ladak if that's
what you choose to do and so it actually
for those people who begin in the peer
support realm it shortens their their
journey to becoming a master's level
counselor
thank you so uh the other piece is so
um
just real quickly if you could pull the
mic just a little bit closer I'm short
yeah especially when you lean back you
get a little far away from it okay so um
I represent I'm the executive director
of an organization known as Horizons
Counseling Center we're one of the first
coding programs in the state of New
Hampshire we uh we opened in 1987 as a
co-occurring program
um I carry two licenses I carry two
licenses and I want to give you an idea
of the practicality of this I carry two
licenses because it uh allows me not
only to provide services to folks once
one of their disorders is not active but
it also it's also necessary for me to
supervise staff I can't just hire staff
who are going to then have to age out
and send their people out so the expense
of hiring people who have to carry two
licenses puts a burden on small
organizations like mine and that's
another reason that this is such an
important difference I was also involved
in writing of the initial
legislation that went through in 2008
creating the unlaid action again in 2010
uh expanding the scope of practice and
the
removal of the full expansion to treat
co-occurring disorders when one disorder
was no longer active was really a
political compromise
and it was a way of saying
um we understand that there's a lot of
territoriality going on and
will defer as long as we can do the work
that we've done but what we've learned
over these last years is having people
transfer to someone else
causes relapse
and that's one of the things that we we
very much want to prevent so we're
hoping that you understand that we're
not looking to be Mental Health
Counselors we're looking to be
co-occurring disorders counselors to
continue that identity I get asked by
Mental Health Counselors all the time
why don't you just be a mental health
counselor and the reality is folks with
co-occurring disorders with substance
use are looking for someone they know
have expertise in how to to treat the
whole person holistically and uh if we
if we did and honestly if I were
interested in treating mental health
that stood alone and not the whole
person then why would I not only get all
of the education that allows me to be
the licsw that I also am
and then an additional 300 hours uh of a
co-occurring disorder specific education
and an additional eight hours
for every two years for every licensing
cycle to make sure that I keep that
education Uh current
thank you
thank you for your testimony
I don't have any other pink cards did
seeing that I will close the the hearing
and uh that will conclude it for the day
and SB 44 is referred to the
thank you Cheryl representative Simon
I've talked to Carol and I've looked